Here's
the basic shape of church history. Just
to wrap our minds around the big
picture, getting the aerial view of what
took place. If you really want to
contemplate what unfolded in the history
of the church, something like this.
First of all, there was the formation
period. This is what we call apostolic
Christianity. This is where Jesus
has initiated or set in motion a
beautiful picture of God that gives rise
to a particular kind of church called
the New Testament church. New Testament
Christianity, the apostolic church.
These are those people in Acts chapter 2
who have all things common and there's
nobody who is in want among them. These
are people whose hearts are overflowing
with other centered self-giving love for
one another because they have gotten a
picture of the other centered
self-giving love of Jesus giving his
life at Calvary.
But then what happened? There was what
the prophets foretold to be a
deformationation
period in church history.
This was warned about in scripture as
we're going to see in a moment. But the
deformationation wasn't merely, listen,
it wasn't merely a deformationation
of practice or ceremony.
What was taking place about the 3rd and
fourth century after the apostolic
period?
What was taking place is that a deformed
a distorted picture of God was being
palmed off on the people on the masses
as though it were the truth. And
gradually as the decades went by, people
began to believe
dark things about God that were foreign
to the love that was manifested in
Christ. And then down through long dark
ages,
there came a point
at which reformation was necessary and
inevitable. People were beginning to
stand up in their liberty and pay
attention to what was going on inside
their hearts and minds. They were
beginning to push back on the ugliness
that was being palmed off on the people
in the name of Jesus. And if it wasn't
Luther,
it would have been somebody else. What
I'm going to suggest to you is that the
reformation is a process and it
continues to this very day. and that you
and I have the privilege, the awesome
privilege of continuing the reformation
started by Luther. And that's why in the
shape of church history, what is
depicted here is that reformation is
going to continue until it produces a
complete restoration
of the apostolic faith. And you and I
have the privilege
by God's grace of being part of that
continuing reformation.
Well, hey there. Thank you for being
here, especially if this is your first
time with us, Adventist or otherwise.
This is our first folks first live
stream after hitting 10,000
subscribers.
Awesome.
Even those of you who are uh Adventists
but quietly watch, Adventists that are
loud and watch, never been an Adventist,
whatever it may be, thank you, thank
you, thank you, thank you. Um, some of
you have reached out to us, some of you
have never reached out to us, wherever
you may be on the spectrum, thank you,
thank you, thank you, and God bless you
in your journey tonight. My question to
you, the viewer,
is your understanding of church history
the same as what we just heard from Tai
Gibson? If so, I hope you'll stick
around because myself and my guest
tonight are going to be diving into this
subject further as we explore some of
the common claims that are made by
restorationist groups across the board
with regards to the preservation of the
church in history. With me to discuss
are a couple of friends of mine,
Pastor Jeremiah. He has been in ministry
since 2016 and he is one of the pastors
at 125 Church in Jonesboro, Arkansas.
His love for God, theology, apologetics,
and people are evident as he teaches the
saints and his labor in apologetics can
be found at the apologetic dog YouTube
channel and website where you will find
lots of engagement with the Church of
Christ in particular.
and Dr. Steven Boyce. He is the pastor
at Harvest Anglican Church, I believe. I
should have probably checked that with
him.
Dr. Boyce is the founder of the Fax
Podcast that primarily focuses on the
church fathers, the apocryphal works,
the canon and text of scripture, and
scriptural exit Jesus. He holds a PhD in
the area of canon and text from
Louisiana Baptist Theological Seminary,
and his main study was on the Gnostic
text and the canonical gospel. His
dissertation covered textual analysis of
CEX H which includes the early petristic
writings that cont uh contained readings
from the Septuagent and the New
Testament. He is currently a
contributing scholar at RTB and an
Anglican apologist. He has pastored in
two churches and helped three church
plants across the country. With that
said, gentlemen,
thank you so much both of you for being
here. I am particularly excited to have
the both of you because uh on this
discussion in particular we have a
Baptist in Anglican and a Presbyterian
which is fitting for the discussion.
How are you guys doing
Miles? Thanks for having me.
Yeah, thanks. Yeah, thanks for having us
on. This will be a good discussion.
Yes. So, first we are going to start by
establishing what the Bible teaches
about the church, what it is, followed
by looking at some classically
Protestant sources with regards to the
Reformation since we heard some
interesting comments there in the intro.
Then we will transition into looking at
the restorationist claims which in the
general are the same across the board
for all of the restorationist groups
such as the SDAs, Mormons, Church of
Christ, etc. But to kick things off,
brothers, what did you think about what
Tai Gibson said in that opening clip?
All right, Stephen, let me let me first
let me have first at bats and you come
and clean up. I thought it was
interesting. He said there's a
deformationation right right out of the
gate. Right out of the the first century
in my understanding, I know you're
you're the historian, but the church is
being sanctified over time. And so I
think it's it's not proper to say right
out of the gate there's a
deformationation. Like to me I see the
church waring against history. I see the
Holy Spirit at work uh sifting out the
heresies. And sure that takes a little
bit of time but I I don't think it's
proper to to set up the trajectory of
church history in terms of
deformationation right after the first
century.
Yeah. And one of the things that I think
that stood out to me was the lack of
evidence in many of his claims. Uh to me
that's the biggest issue. I'm sure he
would argue from certain points, but he
goes through this trajectory of history,
but he doesn't pose any kind of
evidential ideas as to why this third
and fourth century became a problem. I'm
sure he would go through the edict of
Milan and then he would take that into
Constantine and so forth, but there is
no evidence for the claims that he
makes. Um, the one thing that we have to
lose sight of that we don't want to lose
sight of and that we need to lose our
mindsets in is that the early church was
undeveloped in their in their actual
doctrine. Uh, they were not undeveloped
in doctrine. There were things in their
orthopraxy that were working themselves
out and there were different traditions
within that. For example, the apostles
themselves uh had different traditions.
That's why we find different practices
and liturgies say between Peter's
churches and John's churches. So we
should expect some differences. We we
shouldn't expect the orthopraxy to be
identical in every way because some of
it fit the personality of the apostle
that actually started their church or in
the culture that went and started a
church. We wouldn't expect the churches
of Thomas in India to be anything like
the churches of Rome. Uh so when we say
things what he just said in his video uh
there there's this idea that we have
left the truth so far and then we're now
developing and making it better than
what it's ever been when actually that's
not what it means to reform. Uh that's
not even what it means to actually go in
and do restoration. Restoration isn't uh
taking something away and replacing it
because a lot of the way he was speaking
was more replacement than it was
restoration.
Voice come back.
Stephen, you cut out in that last
sentence or two.
No, I was just uh sorry about that.
Yeah, I was just saying that he was
defining things more as replacement than
reformation or restoration. If you ask
me, there's a huge difference between
restoration and reformation by
themselves. But to me, he was speaking
more of replacement than either of those
two.
Yeah. And so he gave you insight, which
we're going to look at some of these
sources um on this sort of stuff and
where he's getting this from ultimately.
Um but he gives you good insight into
how the SDA church thinks they're
restoring apostolic Christianity and
then the the unique spin that they take,
which is different from uh some of the
other restorationist groups, if you
will. Um there is a strain here of what
you could call uh like a moral influence
theology going on. Um so the SDA church
thinks that and he hinted at this that
they are restoring the true character of
God which was warped immediately
following the apostles. So that's what
the deformationation is is talking about
there Jeremiah it deformed after the
apostles because the understanding of
God's character immediately became
tarnished. Then on the rebound, you had
the reformation which led to the
ultimate restoration of apostolic
Christianity which is supposed to be the
SDA church. So they are uh allegedly
restoring the true character of God. So
it's interesting.
Got something else?
Yeah. Well, I'll just say it's just
ironic that the way that Luther because
he seems to have not too big of an issue
with Luther, just that he didn't do
enough. He started something but didn't
finish it. But it's it's ir it's ironic
to me that Luther went to a fifth
century fourth and fifth century monk
and later bishop to be the very person
that he saw as inspiration to doing the
reformation which
was not first or second century church's
father. He was an Augustinian monk and
Luther studying Augustine of Hippo in
North Africa created in him the spark of
reformation thinking which did not come
from before the time frame that he gave.
So reformation idea began in Luther's
mind with Augustine.
So it's just ironic that he would land
that way. So, I I'd like to get y'all's
thoughts on this, too, because when you
think about restoration and replacement,
I that seems like an absolute
contradiction of what Jesus promised in
Matthew 16 about building his church
personally and the gates of hell will
not prevail. And he promised the
disciples that he would send them the
Holy Spirit guiding the church
ultimately into truth. And so to lose
the truth, the the gospel itself, u it
doesn't make sense when you have a
full-blown restoration like like my
understanding. Church history can be
sanctified over time, but you can't lose
that gospel light in toto. So that
that's what I have maybe my biggest
problem with these restorationist
movements. When they claim to be the one
true church that was lost, I'm like,
Jesus didn't lose his brown. Are you
telling me that the Holy Spir spirit
somehow failed in guiding the bride into
all truth?
Which we're going to get into a lot of
this tonight, which is exciting because
we're going to talk about um some of the
foundational issues, which is exactly
what I want to talk about now. Because
before we get too far into it, terms and
definitions are vital in this
discussion.
We heard him use terms and phrases like
church and church history.
Sure.
Church of Christ does this. Mormons do
this. They all use these words. So,
let's establish a couple of foundational
things up front. So, I have an
ecclesiological question for both of
you.
In what ways does scripture use the word
church? And what does that look like in
history?
[Music]
All right, you gota let the Baptist go
first, Stephen.
Uh, the first shall be last. Go ahead.
There you go. So, Ecclesia. Now, this is
how I look at the church, the bride of
the Christ. I would say the church, the
term itself, are the called out ones by
grace through faith apart from our own
works. Now works are not a bad term, but
I just want people to know you got to
believe in the right Jesus in order to
have your sins forgiven. You got to
believe in the gospel of grace. You
can't conflate law and gospel. And as
we've talked about, I've seen your
episodes, true biblical eklesas that are
called out by God. You got to have the
sacraments. You got to have uh the right
understanding of um you you got to have
a good like you said there may be some
practical differences with baptism and
the Lord's supper but you got to have
those intact and so I get that there's
some healthy discussion what that looks
like. I think church polity is crucial
when we're asking about the church
because uh a structure has to be of
authority of now we we talk about
bishops, we talk about pastors,
overseers, deacons like I said there
there's maybe functional differences
that those maybe differ but the core has
to be set in play there.
Yeah, I just added so eklesia is a
called assembly. It's it's a people that
are called out from something into
something else. And Jesus said that he
would build that. Uh and he specifically
in Matthew's gospel said that he would
build that on St. Peter.
And so the apostles themselves
collectively are the very thing that
Jesus built with. Uh he is the chief
cornerstone, but the church is built on
the apostles and the prophets. And so
they are laying that foundation for us
that was going to be passed on,
deposited if you would to the account of
others and faithful men that were
trained to do so. The church is a
structure, not a building. It is a
structure in the sense of that it is a
entity that has organization and spirit
reaction in it. Uh he gave the apostles
authority. He gave them authority in the
church. He gave them authority to give
his words. He gave him authority to
actually go into the nations and begin
churches out of one church. And that
church being the church Jesus Christ. We
see examples of this in Acts. We see
that the church is something where
they're breaking bread. They were taking
Eucharist. So you have the sacraments.
They were baptizing new converts. Uh we
see them instituting uh different
aspects of prayers. They learned creed
very early on. We find this by Acts 4.
What is the prayer that they were doing?
We find that they had a recited prayer
collectively in Acts 4. So I mean we see
the church already beginning in liturgy.
There's lurggical practice already at
the time of Acts 4. Uh the way they're
doing public reading of scripture.
They're surrounding themselves with the
explanation of the apostles doctrine.
They're breaking bread together. Uh
they're singing. We find them uh
bringing uh congregations and people in.
I mean this this was what the church was
initially meant to be from day one in
its conception is that it is an
organized group of people called out by
from God from every tribe, tongue and
nation coming under the banner of Jesus
Christ under the authority of Christ and
those that he gave authority in the
churches being the apostles and those
men that they trained and also passed on
that authority.
Stephen, I have to ask you to drill in a
little bit further just for those in the
audience who may have uh
felt something tickle their ears a
little bit interesting there. You said
you said the church is built upon Peter.
Now, a lot of people in the audience um
we have a big mixed bag here, brother.
And so, you never know whose ears that's
going to hit. Uh a lot of classical
Protestants have no problem hearing
something like that um because we know
exactly what you're talking about. But a
lot of people are not and they're going
to think to themselves, well that's
Roman Catholic. Can you dig into that a
little bit further and what you mean by
that statement?
Sure. Yeah. So, uh I don't mean it the
way the Catholics mean it, but I also
don't mean it the way a lot of Baptists
mean it. So, um there is a balance here
in the construct of Matthew 16. And I
did a whole episode on this and we've
got way more things to cover. So, if
people want to hear my explanation, I
did a whole episode on the life and
ministry of Peter and I actually get
into that. It's on my podcast or I don't
think it's on YouTube because I don't
think we were youtubing at that time.
So, you'd have to go on Spotify or
Apple. Uh, and I discuss what that means
grammatically. Jesus was saying on this
rock I'll build my church was a play on
connective words referring to Peter. But
as I stated as well, Paul goes on to say
that the foundation of the church is on
the apostles plural. So, I don't think
Peter is the only one, but Peter was
going to be the foundation which that
plays out. We see evidence of this in
multiple ways. Just a simple one that we
see in scripture in Acts two. Who is it
that's preaching on Pentecost when many
come to faith and repentance and are
baptized? It's Peter. Uh who is leading
the apostles group? Who is the leader of
that group that we see in Acts chapter
1? It is Peter. Uh that doesn't mean
Peter uh was what has been made of him
unfortunately in some of the Roman
Catholicism twists, but it also doesn't
downplay his role either. uh there was
in the early church from day one a
respect for the sea of Peter in Rome.
Even though there was not the view of
papacy uh that is being held today uh
that is held by many of the Roman
Catholics. Anytime there was an
ecumenical council, anytime there was an
opinion that came from Rome, either in
or North Africa or back over into the
Eastern churches, anytime the Sea of
Peter had a perspective or an idea,
every other church around the world
would hear him because the Sea of Peter
was seen and respected as the very place
that Peter was. So with that being said,
um it does not mean uh what Roman
Catholicism would take it to mean, but
it also is not a downplay of Peter's
role in which Christ would institute and
begin and initiate the very one
leadership of the apostles group was
Peter. Two, his sermon on Pentecost. We
see the evidence of that played out in
Acts one and Acts two alone.
Good. Thank you. Um folks, definitely go
check out his podcast, Facts. You will
find a link to that in the description
box down below. So, if you want to hear
a more in-depth discussion on that, an
important subject, I think, um, go and
check that out. I want to look at an
excerpt now from Dr. Greg Allison's uh,
excerpts of systematic theology from uh,
the section on the church. Something I
think can be beneficial for many in our
audience to help make things even
clearer. Notice what he says here.
quote by combining these various
presentations so this is after he has
given a bunch of scriptural explanations
for what he now says this is the
conclusion we have a minimal concept of
the church it is Christ's followers who
one on a local level worship mature and
evangelize together as a particular
church two on a global level constitute
the universal or catholic church of all
who embrace the Gospel three, when
deceased become part of the heavenly
church, enjoying rest from their earthly
labors and worshiping the Lord face to
face. And four, long for Christ's return
and their participation in their wedding
of the lamb. Close quote.
So
in his book, Dr. Alison first
establishes that the church is the
people of God, the body of Christ, which
means ecclesiology is actually rooted in
God himself. So he explains how really
the church is rooted in God himself. God
established his church both in the
creation of all things of which humans
are a part. And then he regenerates,
transforms and makes one a living stone
in the spiritual temple, the mystical
body of Christ, the new creation.
But then he explains that the church is
also those in heaven who have departed
and worship amongst the host of heaven
where he does a small exog Jesus on
Hebrews 12 and the heavenly mount Zion.
So the church also includes all of the
believers that have come before us and
have joined the heavenly church.
Brothers, I don't know about you all,
but we recite the Apostles Creed in the
liturgy every Lord's Day at my local
church. And we not only mention the one
holy Catholic Church, but also that it
is both visible and invisible. And this
is partly why because we affirm the body
in heaven just as much as the body on
earth. And the two join together in
worship and unite together to have a
little foretaste of what eternity what
is coming every Lord's day. So any
thoughts to add to that before moving
forward? Like I said, I think that will
be beneficial for the people in our
audience, especially former Adventists
who often times struggle to really
understand ecclesiology. And um the
Adventist church, as you as you heard in
the intro, has this very just like the
restorationist churches do, this very
like, well, every other group out there
thinks they're the one true church like
we do. And it's kind of like a needle in
a hay stack, and you just have to make
sure you have the right one, and we can
prove to you that we're the right one.
Um that sort of thing going on. not
understanding that uh all three of us
tonight for example are completely
united in the faith. We are not
sectarians um even though we have
tertiary differences but any thoughts to
add to that either of you?
Yeah, because you brought out a good
distinction between the universal church
and the local church, the visible and
invisible. And so I can speak a little
bit to the restorationist movement,
Church of Christ, because there's no
invisible church with them. It it's just
one visible institution. And virtually
all the even Church of Christ, there's a
few different kind of sects within
there. They all affirm you have to be
added to the Lord's church upon your
baptism, but it's the visible eklesia.
So there's not this universality that
binds all believers together um in the
gospel of grace. And what I love about
where we're coming from is even in some
of these groups, God can save people in
spite of bad theology. Uh the true
gospel. And now that's not to promote
people to, you know, go flying into
these these uh restorationist groups.
But God's grace saves people in spite of
that. And that's why we're doing
episodes like this and so they can hear
that there are true biblical churches
and they can come out of them.
Yeah. I kind of echoing what Miles said.
We we do the Nine Creed every week
except on baptism and confirmation
Sunday we do the apostles and on Trinity
Sunday we do the Athanation Creed. But
in it states we believe in one holy
Catholic and apostolic church. And so
when you look at the gospel narrative,
for example, Jesus sending his disciples
out in Matthew 28 to go into all
nations,
um, instantly you would imagine that a
true church would not just be in a
visible form. Uh, because one, they're
going to be spreading out all over the
world. Two, that message was to be
spread out to the end of the age. Lo, I
am with you to the end of the age. So
there's going to be a major culmination
of different um peoples across the world
at different times until he returns. All
of which would be his church. We see an
example of this in the vision that was
given in the apocalypse of John. Uh we
see a people coming before the throne of
every tribe, tongue and nation saying
worthy is the lamb. You have a a visible
apocalyptic visionary form of what that
actually looks like. people from all
over the world, different language,
different background coming to the lamb
and saying worthy is the lamb. So just
the great commission alone sending them
into a dispersed part of the world. Just
the idea of I am with you to the end of
the age
eliminates
a only view that sees a local body, a
local visible church only to be the
church. Even the great commission
eliminates that possibility just in the
dispersion and in the end of the age
presence of Christ.
Yeah. And just well I don't want to
sidetrack us but with all that in mind
next question because this is also
important in all of this which was
mentioned earlier.
What was the reformation about
specifically with regards to the church?
Yeah.
Now you probably can give better insight
to this cuz immediately I start thinking
about the five solas of the reformation.
Um with solid and solar scriptura um I
do see those relating cuz me and you've
even talked about how scripture being
the ultimate you know judge of all
things. Uh that doesn't divorce how God
has been sanctifying his bride over
time. So me and you probably really
close in that. But you know, I had you
on my channel to talk about
justification by faith alone because
that is the instrumentation in which we
have um our sin uh paid for in full, the
penalty of sin, uh double imputation,
all that. And so this is what I see the
heart of the reformation is there is a
distortion of the gospel and doesn't
mean that there weren't true saints.
Martin Luther wasn't trying to just
restore the one true church. he was
trying to bring legitimate issues to
Rome to try to reform um not make
something brand new. What do you think?
Well, I mean, Luther clearly believed
the church of Rome was the church of
Peter and that it was a good church that
needed to be changed back to what it
was. His view of reformation was to undo
something that developed in it that was
not in its original state.
uh and and I think most of us on here
would agree with them that during the
middle ages a lot of corruption came and
a lot of tradition came and this is why
he held to what he called soul scriptor
Torah although that term has been
greatly abused by people that they call
solo scriptorra today
uh but what what he meant by that
because he defended his position of the
church from the fathers Augustine for
example even Calvin went back he didn't
go back uh to the first and second
century only he quoted Summ he looked at
Sirill of Alexandria. He made multiple
arguments through these eastern and
north African fathers and also these
western fathers to say what we are
proposing to the modern at his time
modern church is an old church that was
taught by these men before us. So what
they would do is they would begin to
design the idea that the church has left
these main tenants. the church was a
good church up to this point. Even when
you look at um the idea of the papacy
for example, uh you have guys like
Gregory, Pope Gregory, even Calvin had
no problem saying one of the last great
popes uh was looking at that time into
the sixth century, into the sixth
century, into the seventh century. He
saw that as a legitimate pope that
rightly understood the church
universally and its practices and its
unity around the gospel, not around him.
Even Calvin had no problem giving props
out to men that were called popes uh
that were used in a mighty way in the
universal church, not just the church of
Rome. So, they saw the church of Rome as
a good thing that it was Peter's church,
but that it had left. It had abandoned
major tenants for other traditions that
gave rise to what became the Roman
Catholic Church of the Middle Ages. And
they were seeking to not find a church,
discover or invent or reproduce, but
rather to go back to where did we lose
the true church from its fall. and that
church that that was in the right form,
let's bring it back into the 16th
century. That's what they were seeking
to do. Again, I the way I listened to
the video at the very beginning of this,
we're speaking about restoration and
reformation and terms like this. They're
speaking of replacement. They're
speaking of a gap period where the
church went missing and now we're having
to do some sort of investigation and
discovery mode. That's not what Luther
and Calvin and these other reformers
were doing. They weren't looking for
something that went missing. They were
they knew where it left. And that's why
I said they use fourth and fifth and
sixth century church fathers and popes
to argue their point. So the man cannot
use the reformers as a template for this
restoration
uh and call it that because they were
using men after the third 2 century into
the six to defend the position of where
the true church was. Clearly reformers
believe the true church was still around
even at least in the sixth century.
I'd like for you to speak to this too
because in my study of church history,
something that was really big for Martin
Luther was kind of Romans 1:16 and 17.
Uh, for I'm not ashamed of the gospel,
for it is the power of God for
salvation. For everyone who believes has
faith to the Jew first and to the Greek,
for in it the righteousness of God is
revealed from faith for faith, as it is
written, the just shall live by faith.
My understanding of what Luther was
putting forth is we are declared
righteous by faith. But that faith will
always entail and produce good works to
the glory of God. And that seemed to
fundamentally undo the sacramental
system. Maybe at that time, maybe you
can speak to that of what Rome was
trying to do with penance. Remember the
95 thesis, purgatory, all of those
things. And Luther is saying
indulgences. No, it's faith in the
savior and his finished work. And so a
beautiful phrase that we see come out of
uh the Protestant Reformation is post
tenderbust lux out of the darkness
light. And I would argue even in the
darkness of Rome there was still that
gospel light and it and it shine forth
with this. Yeah. Solid was the major
swing of the hammer for Luther.
Everything seemed to hinge on that. But
again uh Jeremiah the the key thing to
remember is is that Luther was not
making that argument simply just from
Romans and Galatians. He was making the
army the argument from Romans Galatians
and church fathers like Augustine and
others. And what he was showing is that
there is a chain of custody where faith
alone if you would and and by the way he
did not define that the way that it's
being defined in many of the solid crowd
today in your five solo people. Uh he he
clearly believes sacraments were
important. He clearly believed there was
a mode of works that did a justifying
effect.
Um he's speaking about the person's
position before God
uh and what justifies a man in that
sense. And one of the things that he did
and and I'm sure you've read Luther, all
of you have probably read Luther is he
used a chain of custody that solid so to
speak was being practiced by the church
at these points and the evidence of it
is through the way so and so said this,
so and so said this. So he would use
Augustine very often. Of course he's an
Augustinian monk. He's going to use
Augustine for a lot of things. He
believed Augustine was teaching a form
of solopid. Uh, so again, this isn't
something that went missing and he's
like, "Oh no, the church has been
without the true faith for all these
years and now I'm going to come in and
fix this mess." There were plenty of
other people that tried to rise up
against Rome before Luther. The thing
that has to be remembered about Luther,
I think this is an important point for
both Miles and Jeremiah and myself,
when you look at it, he was very, very
close in proximity to a printing press.
remember when this is a new invention.
Uh he had something at his
I guess
he had something right down the road
from him is the proper way to say that
that others before him who also
challenged the Roman Catholic Church did
not have and that was a printing press
and he was
went viral.
He went viral. He I mean he he hit the
algorithms in the 16th century. say um
Luther's uh access to the printing press
is really what made him popular. In
fact, I would say there's far more
qualified men before him who stood up to
Rome. And this might be some Anglican
bias, but there was a lot of individuals
on the British Isles who spoke up and
distanced themselves from Rome said,
"You've gone into error here. You have
no say so over us. You have no
jurisdiction over us." There was many
protests
against the overstep of Rome long before
Luther. He just happened to be at the
right place in my opinion at the right
time which was by by divine sovereignty.
Uh but his access to the printing press
is what began the process more than
anything. So let's not give Luther like
he's the first guy that rediscovered oh
these are the teachings that have been
going on this whole time. There were
plenty of people in the world already
doing that. He was just in a good place
at a good time to do it. I saw a really
good documentary that um was kind of
pointing to Luther as a good
representation of James 3 cannot contain
you know cannot tame the tongue because
we see a Luther that is bold preaching
the gospel standing up to the the the
corrupt authorities in many ways and yet
this man had many things in his life
that we would not want to emulate today
of course
and
a resource I would like to recommend
people because with the restorationist
groups some of these These bold claims
are that immediate deformation,
you know, let's just look at uh Acts
chapter, you know, the book of Acts, the
first century, and then the
restorationist movement when they began,
everything else doesn't matter. U
there's a book that I really appreciate
long before Lu Luther tracing the heart
of the gospel from Christ to the
reformation. meaning everything that
you've been saying that Luther Calvary
and a lot of these early reformers were
going back to what the church had
already been talking about in terms of
the distinctions with with faith and
works and it's faith it's that inward
trust in the finished work of Christ um
and how we look to scripture as our
ultimate authority and that's not a bad
thing to recognize that the voice of God
that is what informs us of life and
godliness and then yes the church has
been sanctified over time in order to
rightly understand exactly you know
those interpretive um challenges. Yeah.
But but again the we we have to keep
emphasizing this. Luther was not
interested in replacing the church. He
was wanting to reform the church. In
order to reform something you have to
see that thing as once being true and it
still contain truth in it. You have to
remove elements that have distorted,
blinded, or eliminated elements of
truth. And that's what he's seeking to
do. He was willing to compromise on the
the bishop of Rome being the sea of the
churches and its pope being a leader
amongst them. There were areas where
Luther was fine uh with aspects of Rome.
So much as if the pope had the proper uh
if you would he had the proper
accountability that he was not having at
that time. He was not seeking to replace
the church of Rome but to reform it
because he believed it was a true church
and within it it contained truth and
there were things that distorted and
blinded it that needed to go away.
That's reformation. That's not
replacement.
No, go ahead Jeremiah. Yeah, I was I was
wanting your thoughts on this, Stephen.
I think we're we find strong unity with
this, but something I see a problem at
certain places in church history is a
conflation of law and gospel. And to me,
that that is what nullifies the gospel
of grace altogether is when we confuse
how we are to receive the biblical
Christ with faith with a list of
commands aiding in our justification
before God. And I think when we have a
right understanding of Christ's finished
work, God is building his church in real
time. He is the one regenerating hearts
and it is by faith. And it's not to
downplay uh works in the category
properly understood, but do you see that
being kind of a a big thing of how the
gospel gets distorted when it gets
conflated with law?
Oh, absolutely. I mean, everything has
its proper place. I think you would
agree with that. Uh I think you also
have probably read some of the cannons
of Trent, the council of Trent that came
after in response to Luther. They
established that salvation
uh and righteousness can only become a
part of a person's nature by faith. But
again, these were things that the church
was working out at that time. And the
relationship between law and grace and
the relationship between works and faith
was something that became a debate
because of something that happened in
the Middle Ages, not because of
something that happened early on. And so
I do think when we're talking about the
sanctifying process, it's something that
had to happen much much later than the
gentleman in the in the video at the
very beginning of this. It's something
that happened almost by the thou in the
800 900,000 into that range. And so I do
think that what Luther was posing was
important because the church had gotten
it. They had they had backward. They had
it all backward. Uh there was a high
emphasis on one things and I know that
modern apologists obviously I debated uh
Trent Horn and Jimmy Aken on this just
less than a month ago. Um I know they
try to downplay that. Oh no, no. I mean
Trent says it's the Council of Trent
says that it is that. Well, yes, the
Council of Trent did because it needed
clarifying because that's actually not
what they were practicing for quite a
few years. There was a high emphasis on
indulgences. There was a high emphasis
on um particularly when you're dealing
with purgatory and giving to the dead,
praying to the dead. These things were
major implications uh that were that
were being placed on the people and b
and he saw it Luther saw it as a major
burden of placing a workspace on the
whole thing. So again, uh I when I look
at Luther, Luther saw those things as
later developments that added to what
the true faith had always been that Rome
had held to and said, "No, no, we need
to go backward in time." So again, I
agree with you. I'm not saying it's
wrong that to say that these are
important discussion. I'm saying there's
more to the story than that. Even the
Catholic Church was having to iron this
out.
I couldn't have said it any better
myself, Stephen. Well, that's why you
brought me on. No, I'm just kidding.
You guys said so much there that I was
like, "Oh my goodness, there's so much I
could say, but we also have a lot to get
to." But I really appreciate Stephen,
uh, particularly the clarification
around Luther and what was really going
on there. Because I think regardless of
the pocket we're talking about, the
restorationists have their own folklore
about Luther. Roman Catholics have their
own folklore about Luther. Um, various
people out there have their own folklore
about what was going on with Luther. And
it's interesting some of the things
you'll hear today, it's just kind of
ironic that in the age of information,
people seem to have the most
misinformation
um about things in history like this.
Um, and so I think that was something
really important to bring out there is
that like you mentioned, and we're going
to look at some quotes here, folks, from
some classical Protestants to help
establish um that the Reformation was
not about reviving a dead church or
starting a new one. I don't care how
many people out there say that that
charge is often made by again various
parties out there that Luther was
starting a new he was like this
revolutionary. No, that's not at all
what was going on. Not at all. I'm
reading uh Martin Breck's uh biography
of Luther, which is right there, that
yellow book behind me.
Um and he's talking about um well, a
number of these issues. And so these are
kind of fresh on my mind right now. Um
but he wasn't a revolutionary, if you
will. Um, and like we heard in that
intro clip, um, the idea that he was
involved or even had any sort of
understanding around launching a
movement that led to a restoration,
which is rather ironic because in that
biography again, right in the I meant
the Muner controversy with the
Anabaptists. Yes. Right. Yes.
And so to to understand Luther's actual
history and to know what was going on in
Muner with the Anabaptist to think that
Luther had any sort of thing in mind of
what these restorationists oftentimes
try to label and saddle Luther with
shows uh either grave ignorance or
historical revisionism. But I want to
start by looking at a statement from
church historian Philip Schoff from his
book the principles of Protestantism.
Notice he writes quote
in the first place we contemplate the
reformation in its strictly historical
condition
its Catholic union with the past.
This is a vastly important point which
thousands in our day
appear to overlook entirely.
They see in the 31st of October 1517
which is when Martin Luther nailed the
95 uh thesis. It is true the birthday of
the evangelical church and find her
certificate of baptism in the 95 thesis
of Luther but at the same time
cast a deep stain upon the legitimacy of
this birth itself by separating it from
all right relation to the time that went
before.
In this way, all interest is renounced
in the spiritual wealth of the Middle
Ages, which however belongs to us of
right, as fully at least it does to the
church of Rome. And what is worse still,
the lie is given practically to the
Lord's promise itself. Lo, I am with you
always, even to the end of the world.
Close quote. So Dr. Sha's words are just
as true today as they were in the 19th
century. Many modern evangelicals are
not tethered to the past and simply
surrender history when they do that,
which is made manifest when you hear
questions like, "Was no one saved before
Martin Luther?" Um, this isn't the
classical Protestant teaching or belief
that that no one was saved prior to
Martin Luther or that the gospel wasn't
here or something like that. The three
of us would consider ourselves classical
Protestants, but I would go so far as to
use the term some of the reformers did,
such as William Perkins, reformed
Catholics.
Notice what Perkins writes in his
treatis with the self-same name. Quote,
"By a reformed Catholic, I understand
anyone that holds by the same necessary
heads of religion with the Roman church.
Yet so as he par uh pairs off and
rejects all errors in doctrine whereby
the said religion is corrupted. How this
may be done, I've begun to make some
little declaration in this small
treatise. The intent whereof is to show
how near we may come to the present
church of Rome in sunundry points of
religion and wherein we must descent.
Close quote. So, for those that do not
know, William Perkins was an English
reformer, but he didn't speak of the
entire root or trunk of the church being
rotten, but that pairing off needed to
take place. Basically, like a pruning of
branches, a a cleanup, not an entire
overhaul or a revival of something that
was entirely lost. And so, for those
that might be wondering as well, um,
what did he mean by heads of religion?
He means the substance of the Christian
faith, that root, the trunk. And a
reformed Catholic is one who holds to
that same substance but seeks to pair
off doctrinal additions. The key word on
that being additions. You'll see why in
a moment. Now notice in the Augsburg
confession we were just talking about
Luther.
quote,
"In as much then as our churches,
Lutheran churches, descent in no article
of the faith from the church Catholic,
but only omit some abuses which are new
and which have been erroneously accepted
by the corruption of the times contrary
to the intent of the cannons. We pray
that your imperial majesty would
graciously hear both what has been
changed and what were the reasons why
the people were not compelled to observe
those abuses against their conscience."
close quote. No restorationist concept
here. Again, we see the view of
doctrinal accretions, additions that
crept in, needed cleaned up, and the
substance of the faith, the trunk of the
tree was not rotten, but certain
branches were. In the Adventist context,
like I've mentioned, many of them love
to point to Martin Luther to say, "Look
what he said about the papacy being the
antichrist." They love that because they
teach that the pope is the antichrist.
So they love pointing to Luther on that.
Yet this is the same Luther
that said the current Christendom of his
day that was under the papacy was truly
the body of Christ with valid members of
the body of Christ in it which is in
Luther's works volume 40 which is of the
church which speaks to the
distinguishing between the corrupt
office which Stevens kind of alluded to
this a little bit um the corruption of
an office over and against the
individuals within that communion in Dr.
Boyce will appreciate this next one.
John Juel, the uh famed Anglican and
defender of Anglicanism, early uh
Anglican apologist, in part of his
defense of the Church of England, notice
what he says. quote,
"If we do show it plainly that God's
holy gospel, the ancient bishops, and
the primitive church do make on our
side, and that we have not without just
cause uh left these men, and rather have
returned to the apostles and old
Catholic fathers, and if we shall be
found to do the same, not colorably or
craftily, but in good faith with God,
truly, honestly, clearly, and plainly,
and if they themselves, which fly our
doctrine, and would be called Catholics,
shall manifestly see how all these
titles of antiquity, whereof they boast
so much, are quite shaken out of their
hands, and that there is more pith in
this, our cause, than they thought for.
We then hope and trust that none of them
will be so negligent and careless of his
own salvation. But he will at length
study and bethink himself to whether
part uh he were best to join him.
close quote.
No mentality here again folks of the
church having been entirely lost, dead
or corrupted and then needing to be
restored, but rather doctrinal
accretions crept in that needed
corrected. He then goes on to defend
that uh essentially the ancient
substance of the faith has remained
intact. And he also argues the same
thing that John Calvin did, which
Stephven's kind of alluded to a little
bit of this earlier, but um he
essentially claimed, you know,
I if if we're schismatics, the
reformers, then why aren't they Rome
schismatics for leaving the church in
the east? Even saying how the church in
the east didn't have as many doctrinal
accretions. But Luther said that or or
Calvin said that same thing. He said
they the the the Western Roman church
has anatized the church in the east. on
what grounds because they up and just
said that well this office isn't valid.
So now they're deemed schismatics. So he
John essentially makes that same appeal
in the apology. Now obviously our Roman
Catholic friends would disagree with
this but the point being um is that the
history of what the mindset was is very
important. Reformation is not the same
as restoration or or revolution. Last
one here this is from Calvin's
institutes. Quote, "By the unity of the
church, we must understand a unity into
which we feel persuaded that we are
truly engrafted. For unless we are
united with all the other members of
Christ under uh uh under Christ our
head, no hope of the future inheritance
awaits us. Hence the church is called
Catholic or universal." Then he's
talking about he refers back to like
Steven said, Augustine for two or three
cannot be invented without dividing
Christ and this is impossible. What's he
talking about? Two or three what?
Churches. If you have multiple churches,
you have a divided body.
All the elect of God are so joined
together in Christ that they depend on
one head. So they are as it is compacted
into one body, being knit together like
its different members, made truly one by
living together under the same spirit of
God in one faith, hope, and charity,
called not only to the same inheritance
of eternal life, but to participation in
one God and Christ.
For although the sad devastation which
everywhere meets our view may proclaim
that no church remains,
let us know that the death of Christ
produces fruit and that God wonderfully
preserves his church while placing it as
it were in concealment.
Thus it was said of Elijah, "Yet I have
left me 7,000 in Israel." Close quote.
Same idea as the others that we've
looked at. God has always preserved his
church. The root and trunk of the tree
has always remained intact. To invent um
or or create a different church would be
to have two bodies of Christ which would
be divided and cannot be so. And this is
also why definitions are so important
because sometimes we do talk about
multiple churches but we're not talking
about that body of Christ universal.
We're talking about the building
sometimes like I'm going to church. Um
these words have a semantic range but
there is a difference. The key being
there is a difference between corrupting
theological
accidents or accretions within the faith
and the substance of the faith being
poisoned. Restorationist groups don't
tend to make this foundational
distinction. There is a difference
between a group like the seventh day
adventists who have subtracted and taken
away from the substance of the faith and
say the church in the 1300s which still
possessed the substance but it had
additional errors. It had additions not
subtractions from the foundation. The
substance was still possessed and the
errors were additive not subtract.
Adventism, Mormonism, Church of Christ,
they have doctrinal subtractions to the
substance of the Christian faith. But
that is a small sampling for the
audience to see what the classical
Protestant view is of church uh history.
Well, the church in history. Brothers,
any thoughts on that before we
transition to restorationist claims and
ideas?
some when when you talk about
subtractions. What I've noticed with
cult groups, those those restorationists
that are replacing the church, Stephen,
what I notice is usually they capitulate
on the nature of Christ in some way. And
I think they conflate law with grace.
And so what I mean is Jesus said,
"Unless you believe that ego that I am
the eternally creator God, you will die
in your sins." So you can't mess up the
right Jesus. Paul warned of false
Jesuses that don't say save to the
believers at Corinth.
And what I really press is the biblical
Jesus, the sovereign Lord Jesus overall
is the second person of the triune God
who took on flesh and dwelt among us,
lived that perfect sinless life, died at
Calvary, was buried, rose again the
third day, ascended on high, and sits at
the right hand of the father. That's the
biblical Jesus. So you got to believe in
that Jesus. And you have to receive that
Jesus by faith apart from works. And
what I've noticed with all the
different, you know, sectarian groups,
they capitulate on the nature of Christ
or the gospel of grace.
Yeah, they do. And I would think that
the personhood of Christ was the major
debate from day one. uh whether it was
nnosticism, senthianism as the early
form of nnosticism, teditism all the way
down to when you're dealing with
aranism,
um moilism. I mean, there's so many
areas where the person of Christ became
the subject of debate. Uh his
personhood, like you said, the
incarnation, whether you're talking
about he being God himself, uh the
triune God became a major point of
debate. Serial of Alexandria fought to
the death on such a a doctrine. I mean,
we see this in Athanasius's writings,
but the the keys, I think, to a lot of
what was happening here that we have to
not lose sight of again. And John Juel,
Bishop Juel, mentions in that writing
that was shown on the screen, but it
needs to be stated in a broader sense.
We have to we have to lose the mindset
that the Catholics have that everything
was hinging on Rome getting it right. As
if they were the only church. This is
the part that drives me nuts. Um, we
like, oh, the the Catholics think they
were the only, they think they're the
only one true church, but then we give
them that every time we argue that
Christianity is contingent and the true
church was contingent on whether or not
Rome got it right, as if there was no
other church. There were churches around
the world that just don't get the
credit. And there's a reason, two
reasons for that in my opinion. Number
one, the Sea of Peter is that
significant.
Rome was a insignificant church in the
first 300 years because it was heavily
persecuted. The Eastern churches, John
and Andrew's churches were far more
significant than Peter's in the first
300 years of the church.
It wasn't until yes, Constantine and it
wasn't until the legalization of the
edict of Milan that yes, we find the
rise of Rome becoming significant and
politicized in a sense. But the Eastern
churches were the most significant
churches for the first really two to 30
hund years of the church. But what John
Jules is pointing to as well and then in
part of his argument that there was
always a true church not just in Rome
but outside of Rome. We talk about all
these other churches that were formed in
the African continent, the Ethiopic
churches, the Gothic churches as well.
And then you got the Alexandrian
churches, you have the Antiocan
churches, you got the churches of
Jerusalem, you got the churches of
Bzantium, you got the churches of
Inindia. You have churches that are
constantly uh being formed while Rome is
even in its error. And you can go to a
lot of these churches and find that they
were not practicing the same error as
Rome. Uh on the British Isles, you have
for example King Alfred in the 9th
century. King Alfred was opposing the
Roman Catholic Church's oversteps in the
British Isles. One of the major ones,
just for a quick example, is Latin mass.
He didn't want Latin mass on the British
Isles. He wanted the early what would be
considered early English. He wanted mass
to be done in English. He wanted the
universities and he did. They changed it
to the universities to use English. We
say, "Oh, well, the first guy that
really wanted the common language to be
in the form of it's was William
Tinddale, Wickliffe, guys like that."
Sure. If you're talking about men who
actually got it done when it comes to
publicizing translations like Wikliff
from the Vulgate or or Tindale from the
original languages, yes, they began a
major uh if you would reformation of the
word of God. But King Alfred in the 9th
century wanted Latin masses to be out of
the churches because most people around
that area were not speaking Latin and he
wanted the university language to be
that of English because that's what they
spoke on the British Isles. And he
resisted the pope. He called out the
pope. He re he retracted things that
were done in England as a result of
tradition. He reformed areas of the
churches because the Anglican tradition
did not start with King Henry VII
despite what some people think. Uh there
was always a church on the continent.
You had the Celtic churches which were
John's churches. Yes, Augustine of
Canterbury came later in the sixth
century from Rome. But the purpose of
him is different than what Rome thinks
today. But that's another discussion.
But my point is is that if you read John
Juel and you read these others, what
they're trying to tell you is there was
always a true church in Rome and outside
of Rome. We have to make sure we're not
stating that Rome getting the doctrine
right defines where Christianity was at
the time of the Middle Ages. There was
always true churches that were started
by the apostles on the continent of
Africa, Asia, and even in the eastern
parts going over to modern-day Turkey
that were still practicing proper
doctrine. Yes, they had some issues as
well. The truth of the gospel and a true
church is not contingent upon Rome.
There were other true churches of the
apostles actively practicing proper
doctrine. Go ahead.
Yeah. Well, I love the point that you're
driving home that there were true
churches in Rome and maybe in some
Baptist circles and just Protestant
circles at large, you know, everything
Rome bad. You know, sometimes people can
kind of wrongly think of and when you
when we look to the opening chapter in
the book of Romans, verse 7 says to all
those in Rome who are loved by God and
called to be saints. These are the
called out ones. God is already
redeeming a people, calling out a people
by his amazing grace. And so I want to I
want to share with you an absurdity I
deal with with one of the restorationist
movements out the Alex the Campbellites
that call themselves the church of
Christ today towards the end of uh the
epistle to the Romans. So, Romans 16:16
says this, "Greet one another with a
holy kiss. All the churches of Christ
greet you." So, this is the kind of
argumentation I deal with all the time,
Stephen, is, "Oh, you're a
denominational church. We're the church
of Christ the way that Romans 16:16
says, show me where it says the Baptist
church." And so, for one, what I try to
do is just say, "Well, do you greet one
another with the holy kiss if we're
going to be this legalistic with our
reading?" Of course not. And then um I
try to say look all the churches this is
talking about the nature of the eklesia
the called out ones by grace through
faith uh greet you. This is not saying
this is what has to be outside the
church building
uh primarily here in the south. You know
what I'm talking about. But this is the
kind of interaction that I get with a
restorationist group. So it's
interesting the next bishop of Rome
after Peter uh well there's a debate
about the order in which this took
place. He's either second or fourth
which would be uh Clement of Rome who's
mentioned in Philippians.
Clement writes a letter to the churches
of Corenth.
Uh and in that letter it's is called the
first epistle of Clement. um which in it
he opens the letter with these words,
the church of God which sojourns at Rome
to the church of God sojouring in
Corinth to them that are called and
sanctified by the will of God through
our Lord Jesus Christ. Grace and you and
peace from God Almighty through Jesus
Christ.
So he opens a letter. He's a church.
He's the leader. is the bishop of Rome
writing to the church at Corinth. But
notice how he calls them all the church
of God. The church of God at Rome that
sojourns, he calls them sojourers or
pilgrims. And then he calls the church
of Corinth sojourners and pilgrims. To
me, that doesn't sound like um they had
this competition
of
denominationalism today. for example,
uh they were all seen as a church of
God. And to go to what maybe give me
some more feedback if I'm kind of buying
into what you're saying here, Jeremiah.
He states, "What makes them a church of
God?" Well, they were called.
He said they were called to they were
sanctified by the will of God through
the person of Jesus Christ.
And God had brought them to a unifying
peace
also through Christ where God almighty
called them to that universal peace.
Then he goes into instructing them. But
you have the church of Corinth which is
the church of God, the church of Rome
which is the church of God. And they're
all being unified because they're all
being called to the same Jesus who is
sanctifying them the same way and
offering his grace and unity to all the
churches throughout not just a single
location. This debunks the idea of
denominations. What do what do you think
about Clement of Rome's letter opening
to the church of Corinth in the end of
the first century?
Well, like you're saying, there's one
ecclesia. Now, when you have a church of
Christ that just begs the question and
says, "See, it says churches of Christ.
We're the church of Christ." Well,
there's they're assuming so much of of
who the biblical Jesus is and what the
ekles is called out by grace. And so, it
begs the question, it gets back into the
fundamental issues of who is the right
Jesus and how do you receive that Jesus
on the terms that he prescribed. But
yeah, like you're talking about as you
go back into church history, we should
see that strong continuity of the gospel
of grace and Christ sanctifying his
bride over time.
Well, and that's the thing. If if I'm
going to go back and say Jesus said,
this is one of the things that led me to
Anglicanism and finding a church in
succession. Jesus said, "I I will build
my church
and the gates of Hades will not
prevail." Is that an idea or an entity?
Because if that's an idea, that idea can
be lost in somebody's mind. If it's an
actual
tangible entity that has traceable roots
where Jesus says or where God has built
the church through Jesus is the chief
cornerstone with the prophets and the
apostles being laid on it. Is that
structure
able to be traced? They're saying no. I
can show you the succession line of
multiple churches. Whether you're
talking about ones that go back to Peter
in Rome or Andrew and John in the east
or particularly in the British Isles,
you have a mixture of John and you also
have a mixture there of Peter or whether
you're talking about the Antiocan
churches going back to Peter or whether
you're talking about the Jerusalem
churches going back to St. James or
whether you're talking about Matthew's
churches in the uh northern parts of
Africa or John Mark going down to
Alexandria or Thomas into India. Every
single one of these churches has the
succession line of the bishops who are
entrusted by the laying on of hands down
through the ages to this day. That's
what Tertullian was arguing in North
Africa when he was arguing for the fact
that we have a chain of custody. We have
the shore documents and deeds to the
property, the church. How do you know
what a church was when Tertullian was
alive? when he was defending the
churches in North Africa, he had deeds.
What were the deeds? The deeds were the
apostles text. The churches that had the
apostles text were the churches that
were started by the apostles. They had
the text. They also had the succession
leaders that were given to the churches
to guard the text, the deposit. So when
you find the documents, which by the
way, if you were to go through first
clement, you will find this argument
being made where he reminds them of the
letters that Paul had already instructed
them about gospel unity. He's reminding
them of something they already have.
Polycarp, a disciple of John, when he
writes his letter to the Philippians,
for example, he actually appeals to
Paul's authority over his as a bishop.
He says, "Paul wrote to you these
things. go seek or search them in his
letter to you and in doing so you will
increase your faith. Two things. Number
one, Polycarp assumed that the church of
Philippi, which he was writing to around
the 130s, still had the original letter
of Paul, or at least a very near copy of
the letter of Paul just under 100 years
before that they still had the letter.
Two, that letter of Paul had spiritual,
sanctifying, faithbuing qualities in the
letter. and Polycarp writing to the
bishops. So whether you're talking about
Ignatius to its bishops, all these
churches had traceable lineages through
documents, the New Testament, and
bishops who are entrusted to those
documents. To this day, I can pull out
to you the succession line of my church
and the priests that I go to and how
they go back to St. Peter and John. The
Catholics can do it with Peter.
Antiocans can do it all the way back to
Peter. The churches of Alexandria, the
Coptic churches can do it all the way
back to Mark. Ethiopic churches can do
it to Matthew. We can go on and on in
here. We have succession lines that show
where the church has always been through
every year. We don't have to put our
hands on our eyes and grasp at
something. We have a tangible tradition
that goes back from Jesus and his
apostles and his great commission to
them. We know where they went. We know
what churches they started. We know the
names of the men's they put the men they
put their hands on their heads and the
men they put their hand on heads and
hand on head all the way to today. The
problem is is within those churches,
what you're seeing in these these
statements that are being made that were
just read to us by Miles is that some of
those churches and a big big church out
of all of those was Peter's th those
churches adopted traditions that were
not in its original form. And so they
have to be removed to go back to its
pure form. That is what the reformation
was all about. not to build new
churches, not to start new churches, not
to create or discover new churches, but
they already knew where the churches
were. Now, the reason the reformation is
significant is because the Roman
Catholic Church had taken over the West.
You don't see a lot what's going on in
India, do you? You don't see a lot about
this going on in Africa. They were very
insignificant as it related to the
western church because the headquarters
of not only power and then the
headquarters of rule had already
established itself in the west. The west
became the predominant church but they
were not the only church. The silent
churches in Africa the silent churches
particularly over in in East Asia uh
they were not without practice. They
were not without liturgy. They were not
without direction. They were not without
faith. Those churches have their
tradition and history. They're just in a
minor, softer, quieter voice because the
west made the influence in the world at
that time. And the only ones we seeing
push back from that for particularly in
the reformation are these men that we
find in places like Geneva and in uh
places of Rome uh places also outside of
that into Great Britain and in France.
We find this happening during this time
and the printing press made this
universal. We have to keep in mind our
history. What gave rise to what the
printing press was able to create a
ripple effect across the universal globe
that no one else could do before that
point. Not to the level that we saw in
the reformation. There were oppositions
to this already happening. There were
pre-reformationations all over the
place. That's what these men are saying.
The true church was always there saying,
"Uh, Rome, you're out of hand." We have
North African churches writing saying,
"Hey, you need to remove the bishop
here. The bishop of Rome is bullying
people out of the church. That's not his
call." We see this even in again Alfred
and others in the 9th century in the
British Isles opposing the Roman
Catholic Church for overststepping its
authority and they were being called to
go back and be put an accountable check.
This happened all through the ages. The
difference at the time of the
reformation is I believe the printing
press. It made the major universal chain
reaction.
Wow. There's just like so much good
information here. And again, it just
makes me want to like
we talked to folks before we started
this and Stephen was like, I don't know
how we're going to get through like the
first few questions.
And this is exactly why because if I
were to piggyback on a lot of that
stuff, um, we would end up going into a
lot of other interesting things.
Sorry for rambling, gentlemen.
No, no, no. This is that's great. Thank
you for real. Thank you. Um, because
it's just again there's there's a lot of
folklore. There's a lot of folklore, not
just from restorationist groups, but
from all sorts of people out there. And
so, I think information like that is um
valuable. And again, folks, you can
check out his podcast. He talks a lot
about these sorts of things. Um, the
link to that is in the description box
down below. Now, we're going to make a
transition point here. It's been about
an hour and 15 minutes.
And what's that?
I was just breathing. That's all right.
We're good.
No, you're we're good.
Okay. I didn't know if that was like a
subtle hand raise, you know, the the the
slight exhale. But, brothers, part of
our mission at Answering Adventism is to
educate the body of Christ on the
theological dangers of Adventism. That
would include you both as well as
leaders within the body of Christ, but
also the audience. First, I want to
establish that the SDA movement is
indeed a restorationist sect. They are
sectarians in this regard. You may
encounter some Adventists that will deny
this for v uh various reasons. But
first, notice a short quote from SDA
historian George Knight. This is from
his book, Search for Identity. Notice
what he says. Quote,
"The restorationists rejected the view
that the Reformation was something that
happened only in the 16th century.
Rather, the Reformation began in the
16th century, but would not be completed
until the last vestigages of tradition
were gone and the teachings of the
Bible, especially the New Testament,
were firmly in place in the church. the
task of the restorationist movement was
to complete the unfinished reformation.
He then goes on to say, "It is important
to recognize the impact of the
Anabaptist mentality, restorationism,
and Wesleyanism on the understandings
and development of Adventism."
Close quote.
So the SDA movement is far more in line
with the radical reformers, the
Anabaptists,
and they were heavily influenced not
just by that mentality, but also the
restorationist mentality of the church
being apostate and needing restored.
Those of you in the audience that know
about Millerism will know that
restorationism, specifically a great
apostasy, deformationation, like Ty
Gibson said, that was foundational to
Millerism.
And so these seventh day Adventists
inherited that mindset out of that. But
as you see, Dr. Knight alludes to the
idea that their movement is a
restoration of the pure teachings of the
Bible just like every restorationist
sect uh sect thinks that they are
despite contradicting one another.
Gentlemen, before moving forward,
why is that inherent claim
that the restorationist movement
finished what the reformation started?
Okay, your mic definitely is not working
now.
Uh,
he even asked us on the side, is my mic
working? And I said it was. Hey, I put
it in past tense. I said it was. I
didn't say it is. So, God silence
another Baptist today, folks. Uh, I I'll
go ahead. I will go ahead and start
answering this while he gets his mic
situated. Um, no, they did. How could
they? And I don't want to be repetitive
here. Again, um, I do think that the
Anabaptists in that mindset did give
rise to bad thought. Th this is the
extremism
uh mentality because what what
extremists do in church history is they
throw out the baby with the bathwater.
Uh they take everything and throw it
out. They throw everything. And so when
you're talking about the revisions or
the restorationists here, they did not
complete something because completing
something uh would insinuate that the
reformers uh l lacked the ability to
accomplish. There you go. They lacked
the ability to accomplish something they
were set out to do. I think if you were
to investigate Luther, I don't think he
believed that he didn't do what was
needed or at least put out there. And
these restorationists are not completing
what he started anyway. In fact, they're
opposing a lot of things that he started
and they gone to a extreme. He was
seeing this in his own day. I mean, you
guys do probably realize as well that,
you know, there were times where
Luther's friends faked his death and uh
there were times where they thought he
was dead and then Lutheran were going
out and hanging Catholic priests and
killing them and he found out about it
and he was furious. He was furious that
Lutheran were killing Catholic Catholic
anointed uh succession priests. It
bothered him. He was angry about it.
There were extremists when he was still
alive. He didn't believe that he was
starting something that the next
generation need to pick up and finish
for him. He believed what needed to be
said was said. He believed he was
thorough.
uh most of the reformers believed what
they had begun was not something that
needed some sort of completing that that
they're referring to and the what
they're completing is not in keeping
with what the Protestant reformers were
trying to do anyway because the
Protestant reformers go back to the
early church church writers and
petristics like Chris Austin like serial
like Augustine like Basil they go back
and quote these men I don't see the
restorationists doing that They're
calling these men apostates. So, how
could they be completing what they
started when they're going back to the
fourth, fifth, and sixth century
Petristics when this group's calling
them apostates? You can't be doing the
same work. So, can you hear me? Okay.
Now,
you're back.
Yes. This Baptist is no longer silenced.
Um, something you were talking about
earlier going back to the the early
church, the documents, the documents. We
can prove it. we can show, you know, who
the true church is that comes from the
apostles teaching. Now, I like this
because even even though I would be on
the the solo scripturous side, to me,
this is a encouragement to say, "Hey,
Christ has been building his church for
2,000 years." Not that uh Christ failed
somewhere along the way or the Holy
Spirit failed somewhere along the way to
guide the true church into all truth.
But I was wanting to bring something up,
Stephen, because you're talking about
the documents. Oh, yeah. Well, no creed
but Christ, Jeremiah, Stephen.
And this is and but this to me is goes
back to Miles's original question.
Are they continuing what you know,
Luther began like they say from the re
reformation or um um into the uh
restoration? It can't be the the thing
you this the thing you've been drumming
all night is Luther and them were going
back to the early church. Not just
Luther, right? Calvin, Augustine, all
these people, they're going to the early
church. But a dead giveaway of the
restorationist mindset is a
self-defeating claim of no creed but
Christ. When I had you on my channel,
I'm out of the church of Christ births
hyper predtoism. And it's all built on
this assumption. No creed but Christ. Of
course, the church has been wrong for
2,000 years. It don't matter. And
unfortunately, a lot of times it gets
under the umbrella of solo scriptura,
but like you said, that gets distorted
into a solo
um no creed but Christ. It's just me, my
Bible under a tree, no creed but Christ.
And I think that's a dead giveaway of a
restorationist sectarian cultlike
mindset that's going to capitulate once
again on the nature of the true Jesus
and the gospel of grace that is to be
received by faith apart from works. I I
think another thing is as well that is
the true church Jeremiah as a repenting
church not a perfect one.
Uh when we look at the the Anglican
church is a very repentive church. We
have an ugly history at times. Rome has
an ugly history at times. Uh the the
true church is not a perfect church. I
think about the prayer that we pray uh
quite often in the Anglican church for
the universal church. It reads this way.
Gracious Father, we pray that the hol
that thy holy Catholic Church fill it
with all truth and all truth with all
peace. Where it is corrupt, purify it.
Where it is in error, direct it. Where
in anything it is a miss, reform it.
Where it is right, strengthen it. Where
it is in want, provide for it. For where
it is divided, reunite it. For the sake
of Jesus Christ, thy son, our savior.
Amen. And these are prayers that we pray
regularly in the Anglican church that
God would unify his one holy Catholic
and apostolic church. But that where it
is failing in truth, in unity, in
corruption, it's inviting God to work in
his church.
Uh he is washing his church. We see this
illustration in Ephesians 5
with the water. He's washing it. He's
purifying it like like a bride adorns
herself. The church is being washed and
adorned. Uh we are a repentive people.
The sign of a true church is not just a
church of faith. It's a church of faith
and repentance where faith failed. And
that's what we're looking for here too.
And and we see evidence of this
throughout the churches in their history
as well.
Stephen, you mentioned something there
that I think is just so important too
that I think is a stark contrast. Um,
especially obviously I'm thinking about
Adventism a lot, but even just in the
context of restorationist groups period
is this sort of hyper aversion to that
unity. That unity is actually seen as
fearful. Um, I can't tell you how often
I get called an ecumenist. Um, or like
whatever term it may be. Um, because I
don't have this hyper sectarian
understanding that, believe it or not, I
actually pray for for the church to be
united.
I pray for the schisms to be mended. I
pray for there to be unity um on on the
fundamentals and and liberty and freedom
in the uh non-essentials um and that we
can overcome these sorts of things. Yet
a lot of these groups will say that's
evidence of our group being correct
because what insert whatever figure in
the Adventist context Ellen White said
that there was going to be a time where
Protestants are going to unite with
Catholics and that's going to prove that
we're correct because prophecy foretold
this and these sorts of things. And so
it's just interesting that you know you
just prayed for for unity um whereas a
lot of these groups are actually um
saying that sectarianism is noble. See,
and this is an interesting point. Uh,
you know, no offense to my Baptist
brother down there. When the Baptist
first came on the scene originally, this
was something that they were writing
about. And when you look at John Smith,
uh, you look at others who are
participating in this view of
ecumenical, if you would. Their view was
that they were fulfilling the prophecy
of the book of Revelation. I I've said
it multiple times. Uh, you see this in
these sectarian churches. You see this
even in Baptist churches that if if the
eastern church and the western church
ever uh united
uh when you look at their major fallway
with the filioquay in the 11th century,
they had many other issues brewing
before that.
But if the church of the west, the
church of the east ever came together
along with the Anglican church and the
British Isles, I think what people would
start saying is this is the end times.
This this is the one world religion.
This this is it. This is the antichrist.
And um it's sad that if we think about
the the apostles churches who have been
divided
for many many years and recently the
Coptic church, Mark's churches for the
first time broke communion with uh Rome.
Just this calendar year, the first time
since Peter and Mark were alive
together, they broke communion.
Um
when you think about some people don't
care but that that's a that is a major
thing. Uh you know even the Anglican
Communion had a break with its mother
church in in England over homosexual and
gay marriages and things like that.
That's the first time since the 600 601
that we haven't had mother church uh
watch over us even though the majority
of the Anglicans are the conservative
ones. I mean you look at these things
are heartbreaking but to see repentance
and reconciliation
as like fulfilling
prophecies like oh this is it the one
world religion this is it. It's like did
that what Jesus prayed for in the
garden? I mean is that not John 17? Make
them one
as you and I are one. I mean good grief.
God forbid that we would come back to
unity.
Yeah.
Go ahead. Defend yourself. Baptist.
No, no, I'm going to let that stand. I I
hope we're showing how truth unites and
we're saying truth also will divide
where it needs to happen and we trust
God and his sovereignty in that. I was
going to say, you know, I kind of bring
a little bit of perspective with the
church Christ and they divide within
themselves because they have this
restorationist mindset that okay, um,
when we're doing the Lord's supper, my
interpretation, which you got to think
in their minds, is you have to obey
Christ according to my interpretation.
We just speak what the Bible speaks.
And, oh, your church thinks it's many
cups during the Lord's supper. Oh,
you're anathema. And so I'm just wanting
to shine a little light on some of these
restorationist groups. Obviously the
Adventist are going to be different for
so many things with the Church of
Christ, but the church of Christ divides
against themselves. And so I think this
goes handinhand with what we've been
talking about how we we should be
seeking unity on the gospel and unity on
tertiary things that we can continue to
sharpen one another. Every time I listen
to Dr. boy speak, I learned something
new, especially with church history um
and how Christ has been building his
bride. And I loved how he alluded to
Ephesians chapter 5 because Christ has
been sanctifying, washing his bride. So,
I think it's fundamentally wrong to look
at church history as an immediate just
jumped off the cliff. Uh because the
reformation wasn't to restore what was
lost. No, Christ has been sanctifying
his bride over time. So I just Miles I I
just wanted to highlight that the Church
of Christ they're so legalism they've
lost the the the grace law distinction
where it's all law and it's all under
the banner obey obey the gospel and
obviously we affirm that but what does
that mean you know what I mean but um
but yeah when when obedience is the bar
then to have any disagreement on any
meaningful interpretation there's going
to be schism anathema no unity
Well, that's the problem with
sectarianism and schism, it bruise more.
And that's why so many organizations
have no traceable lineage. And when you
look at these churches, and this is,
this sounds harsh, but I'm going to say
it. They don't have a traceable,
tangible church. So, what do they have
to do? Throw it all out.
We're the true church because you have
nothing to trace. We do. See, this is
the problem with sectarianism.
Sectarianism bruts more sectarians. As I
always say, sectarians going to sect.
That's what they do. They're going to
create more sect and then more sect. And
the thing is is that you've got hundreds
of breaks and splinters and breaks and
splinters and breaks and splinters that
you can't trace the truth, much less
your church.
And this is why that you this is why you
have to absolutely throw all of history
out. Claim you are what was in the first
century, but can't show it. You can't
prove it. you don't have any tangible
evidence to demonstrate it. Whereas the
apostles churches, this is why there's a
major resurgence in our generation men
that are going back to the Roman
Catholic Church. And I think they're
making a hasty move because there is a
reformation happening in Roman
Catholicism today in a good way.
I have friends that are in it. Uh I I I
join them from the Anglican viewpoint
and cheer them on. But there's a massive
growth in Roman Catholicism, Eastern
Orthodoxy, Anglicanism, and forms of
Lutheranism in the world today going
back to ancient practices. And it's our
generation that's going back to it. I
just read recently where the Roman
Catholic Church in the United States had
its highest attendance on Eastern Sunday
and its I highest baptisms since the
1980s. There has been a massive
resurgence. I mean, you've seen it on
the news. How many Hollywood actors and
actresses, how many major uh world
leaders and major uh people who are
influential in apologetics or their
wives are all going into an ancient
practice of the church because what
people are waking up to see is that
sectarianism does not work. It has no
tangible traceable significance in the
historic church. And what they do is
they see the appeal of Roman
Catholicism. Oh, this goes back to St.
Peter and all of its great traditions
and magnificence and glory and and it
does. Of course, they have to adopt some
things in my opinion that are unhealthy.
But what that's what drew me into
Anglicanism. It's like, well, the church
goes back to the very beginning. We go
back to John. We go back to the Celtic
churches and we go back to Peter's
churches. We have a significant history
that has a tangible traceable lineage.
And they can't have that. They don't
have that. So the only move they have is
to throw it away and say, "No, no, no.
We've lost the definition of truth.
We've rediscovered it." No, no, no.
We've lost the definition of the church.
We're it because we say so. You can't
prove it. You don't have evidence. You
don't have lineage. You don't have
documents. As Tertullian said,
speak where the Bible speaks, Stephen.
Where are your where are your shore
documents to prove? This is the argument
with Tertullan.
Almost anybody that's listening this
probably has a vehicle. You have a you
have a title that goes with your car. To
have the title with the same VIN number
as your vehicle is to say that that is
the proof the evidence that that vehicle
belongs in the name on the title, your
name. you to to to remove the car and
the title and to separate that or to
have a title with a different VIN number
than the vehicle is a confusion and it's
illegal. You don't have e evidence to
prove that that vehicle belongs to you
because the title does not match the VIN
number as that is on the vehicle.
You have no proof that you belong to the
church. You have no proof. You have no
documents to show that church its title
and my church and the biblical church
are all matched. We have the same VIN
number. You don't have that. See, we can
do that. We can do it. We can do it by
succession. We can do it by our document
of faith. We can do it by our lineage.
That's the difference between an
apostles church and these sectarian
churches. They have no traceable
lineage. And that's what Tertullian
said. Any church that was seen outside
of having those proofs of the tangible
documents of succession and the
documents of the the apostles themselves
is a church under skepticism.
And these churches are not just
skeptical. They are beyond skeptical.
They they're sectarianism off of
sectarianism. They're not even sectarian
by themselves, right?
They're a branch of sectarianism. And
forgive me, but I'm just going to speak
the truth. You have no history. You have
no tangible facts. You are wishful
thinking and you have to redefine
history to be who you are. And by that
definition, you are a false church by
the apostolic lineage. Not saying that
you have all faults in the sense that
you're damnable. Some of you may be, but
in the sense of you have no attachment
to the apostles. You cannot claim them.
You don't know them. They don't know
you. You're not in their lineage. Sorry,
I bring this up all the time about how
um you know, a big thing that and some
of this comes from having grown up in
Adventism and and knowing the script and
the talking points and all that sort of
stuff and having said them over and over
and over and over and over again and
then realizing what I do now. Um uh I'm
always big on the Adventist leadership
needs to own that they are their own
thing. You're not Protestant. You're not
you don't have a history and a lineage.
this this sort of myth about like, well,
we're apostolic truth restored. But then
you read in their articles where they're
saying stuff like, well, we have a
present truth gospel. No one before us
preached this. It's a special end times
gospel that started in 1844 and only we
have it, but it's apostolic in origin.
Um, but it's only for the end times,
okay?
And the end times started in post 1844.
You get this sort of thing going on.
It's like, no, you need to just own that
you're your own thing. The early
Adventists, which we're about to see a
quote from here, had no no issue owning
this. They That's what their whole thing
was is no, no, we are the one true
thing, were completely distinct and
separate from all of that. But now, as
time has gone on, all of these sects
have to find a way to remain relevant,
to keep the machine fueled, to keep
things going on. So, they've all pivoted
now to this sort of like, well, at least
in the Adventist case, you know, we're
just like you, brother. You know, we're
we're we're Protestants. We believe in
the Trinity. We believe in the gospel.
And it's like, no, we justification by
faith. Well, you have your own
dictionary. And that's been part of the
outflow and product and result of time
going on because time is the
restorationist group's biggest enemy.
This is a quote from James White,
husband to the Adventist prophetus,
Ellen White. He wrote this in the
Adventist church's paper, The Review and
Herald, in 1856. Notice
not to be confused with James White
modern day. Go ahead.
No, not at all. Not James R. White. This
is James S. White.
Quote, "The mystery of iniquity began to
work in the church in Paul's day.
It finally crowded out the simplicity of
the gospel and corrupted the doctrine of
Christ, and the church went into the
wilderness."
Martin Luther and other reformers arose
in the strength of God and with the word
and spirit made mighty strides in the
reformation. The greatest fault we find
in the reformation
is the reformers stopped reforming. Had
they gone on and onward till they'd left
the last vestage of papacy behind, such
as natural immortality, sprinkling the
Trinity, and Sunday keeping, the church
would now be free from her unscriptural
errors. Close quote. So, a little
glimpse of the Anabaptist mentality that
George Knight mentioned with the claim
that the reformers didn't go far enough.
That's also what Ty Gibson at the
beginning was getting at. And he uses
one of the restorationists favorite
arguments. He appeals to Luther to say
he was the first domino in leading the
church out of the Babylonian captivity
and being restored. Which when you don't
view the church the same way as Martin
Luther did appealing to him on the
Babylonian captivity of the church is
merely superficial. Yep.
But we see his utilization of a very
common scriptural proof text that is
often cited by restorationists and that
is second uh Thessalonians specifically
2 verse three. Notice what it says.
Now I beseech you brethren by the coming
of our Lord Jesus Christ. I'm also
citing it in the King James Stephen
because often times these groups also
tend to love the King James. Maybe they
say
we're going to need to use the King
James to get the exact wording that our
restorationist friends like to use.
Anglican translation. Just saying.
That is correct.
Anglican translation. Don't get me
started. Go ahead,
folks. His background was in textual
work. So, um, we could spin off into
that. And I've talked about having him
come back to uh do some stuff regarding
the the Adventist church's claims um
regarding uh inspiration and inherency,
etc. But it's uh the apostle writes,
"Now we beseech you, brethren, by the
coming of our Lord Jesus Christ, and by
our gathering together unto him, that ye
be not soon shaken in mind or be
troubled, neither by spirit, nor by
word, nor by letter, as from us, as that
the day of Christ is at hand.
Let no man deceive you by any means, for
that day shall not come, except there
come a falling away first, and that man
of sin be revealed, the son of
predition, who opposeth and exaltth
himself above all that is called God, or
that is worshiped, so that he as God
siteth in the temple of God, showing
himself that he is God. Now the claim
usually goes that this is referring to a
great apostasy
which took place immediately after the
apostles.
So my question for both of you is that
what 2 Thessalonians 2 is referring to
that the church would go entirely
apostate after the apostles and need
restored or is something else going on
here?
Well, is my mic work? I I'll try to get
first crack. you're good.
Um, no, that's a great question,
Stephen, because this kind of goes back
to our last podcast that we did. Um, and
I wanted to also sprinkle in, um, I love
the depth of church history, how we can
talk on that level. What I've noticed
with interacting with restorationists is
they don't care about church history.
So, how do we continue that apologetic?
I mean, we can point to the, you know,
uh, Matthew 16:18 about saying, well,
history matters because Christ um, has
been building his church and so forth,
but what I've found to be really, um,
imperative, especially with the church
of Christ, full predtoist, is those
stellar biblical arguments that the
church has always held on to. So I want
to give people the impression um church
history invaluable how Christ has been
sanctifying his bride and we we we build
on the shoulders of giants to point
people back to the living voice of God.
That's why I always talk about the
gospel of grace. We can demonstrate our
case. You know what I mean? And so
second Thessalonians chapter 2 I think
has a lot to do with esquetology. And
man, you we we talked about how because
uh I can't remember which verse, but
it's talking about God will send a
spirit of stuper. God has on one hand
always been sovereign over the bride,
allowing people to continue in
rebellion, handing them over uh to a
repbate mind. And then then there's the
man of lawlessness. Many have
interpreted to always be the spirit of
the age. And many have also said, but it
seems like right before Christ returns,
there's going to be, you know, this kind
of battle of Armageddon that's been
typified throughout church history. And
to me, this is talking about um it's
it's very esqueological
um and pointing maybe to that final day
when Jesus Christ will return to restore
all things. But it doesn't get you some
vague restorationist, you know, you
know, so many couple hundred years ago.
You know, this the idea that there was
going to be apostasy. We see evidence of
this. We see evidence of apostasy very
early on while the apostles were living.
Yes. Um, one of the things that John
said is that people left them.
They were of us, but they were not. They
were with us, but they were not really
of us. If they had been of us, they
would have continued with us. But I want
to point out what John also says in
First John to the elect lady, excuse me,
second John to the elect lady. He makes
the statement, "For the true sake which
dwells in us and shall be with us
forever."
Um, one of the things he was encouraged
at that though there were people coming
into houses and distorting the truth
that the truth remains in God's people
and God's people contain the Holy Spirit
because he's just talking about the
spirit of truth. This was prayed back in
the time of John's gospel. um when the
spirit of truth comes uh and he will
sanctify the sanctification of the word
of God through the spirit will sanctify
them through truth.
John didn't believe the truth was going
to disappear that it would remain in the
body of believers and that is the
church. He says it'll remain with us
forever. Apostasy was alive when the
apostles were around. Apostasy was alive
after they left. But so was the truth.
As long as the spirit was in the world,
the truth remained in the world. Where?
In the body of God's chosen people.
John said it. So yes, there was a
falling away. We see evidence of it
innosticism. We see evidence of it in
various forms of destruction. Um people
destructive heresies.
There's entire writings the early church
fathers wrote books called against
heresies. Or you think that well that's
in within a hundred years of the church
being formed. They're writing documents
against these heresies and it wasn't one
or two or three. There's men that we've
never even heard of coming up with
heresies that have been debunked and the
church took care of it. The big ones are
the ones that took it to ecumenical
councils like Aryanism and historianism
and others. But when it comes to this
area, we cannot forget what the apostles
also said that the truth abides and
remains in us forever. That's what Jesus
meant when he said until the end of the
age. If the spirit is in the world,
because what you have to conclude is if
the truth went disappearing
and apostles took over, then the spirit
of God that Jesus promised would come in
John 14 and remain with them
not only came but left and did not
reappear again until these churches
formed. Because when the spirit is here,
truth is here and the truth remains. And
the spirit remains. If you want to use
Paul, Paul also said that you are the
temple of the Holy Spirit and the spirit
of God remains in his people. That means
there's a true saint somewhere in the
world that has the Holy Spirit and the
truth abides with that person. But in
that context that Paul was speaking of
is of a temple of a group of people
being made up of the body of Christ. If
you read the whole context, we don't
have time to go through that. But let's
just let's not just cherrypick Paul
here. Let's talk about Paul's view of
the Holy Spirit in light of what Jesus
promised in John 14. The spirit would
come and remain and abide.
So if apostasy took over the church and
there was no more truth, then you have
to conclude that the spirit of God left
for a long time and abandon his people.
That's a problem. Something else I want
to mention is Jesus talked about the
kingdom of God is at hand. It's here.
It's near. It's upon them. That Jesus is
the king and he brings his rule and his
kingdom and it's an everlasting kingdom.
This once again gets back into
esquetology.
Jesus if if the if the kingdom of God
came and left, it's not an eternal
kingdom. And so that's why we we hold to
an already not yet. We we have an
inaugurated kingdom that cannot fail.
That John or Romans chapter 14 Paul says
u that the kingdom of God is not eating
and drinking and being married but it's
joy and peace in the Holy Spirit that
indwells saints. Now we are awaiting a
consummation of Christ to return and to
restore all things. You have a problem
if the kingdom was totally lost because
you would not have an everlasting
kingdom.
Yeah. The thing that's interesting about
that text, and again there's a couple
others that they point to, but that's
just a very big one that I often hear.
Um the text nowhere states or indicates
that there would be a universal
apostasy.
Right. Right. Right. Right. Exactly.
Which is is what is being read into this
that
if there's an apostasy, it must mean
that there was this great apostasy which
the church went completely silent. And
then when I what I found in my
experience at least is then when you
start to press them on this, you then
get some sort of like, well, the church
was here, but we don't really know where
it was. There was just this big gap from
the apostles to Martin Luther,
and we don't really know where the the
church was. And like I'll get
Adventists, for example, that have asked
me this, and I say it was universal.
Like they'll say, "Where was the
church?" I'll say, "It was universal.
It was Catholic. universal, not Roman
Catholic, which is what they tend to
often lump under that, but it was
universal. Um, and then I have to
remember that for people that are in
that mindset, that's a very hard thing
for them to grasp because they have this
very like,
well, they just have that restorationist
sort of lens on. It's just kind of like,
well, that's just what it is. They don't
really have an understanding of anything
prior to Martin Luther other than well
somewhere back with the apostles and
then it kind of just went dark. But
that's been my experience anyways. It's
like well the church was here but um not
really. It wasn't really here you know
it's just kind of who knows somewhere
out there someone and then really there
was this big rumbling that started in
the 16th century.
I can tell you where I can tell you
where they were. I can show you their
their evidence and I can show you their
liturgy and I can show you their
writings,
but you got to take time to study it.
And Luther, if you just read him, he'll
tell you where they were, too. They
clearly don't read him close enough.
Well, the thing that's interesting, too,
at least in the Adventist context, is
you'll often times start to uh talk
about the individuals. Now, I don't know
exactly who you're talking about. I
don't know up to what period you're
talking about, but um you you'll appeal
to some of those people and you'll get
this uh sort of catch 22 of either that
person was a heretic and an apostate. I
mean, I've had them tell me things like
Erynaeus was a heretic.
Oh,
yeah. Athanasius was a heretic, but
they're trinitarians, but they're
trinitarians, they'll tell you.
So, um, there's a lot of of, um, well, a
catch22 of like having to anathematize
these individuals at the behest of
upholding the the restorationism, but at
the same time having to then deal with
the problem of like, well, then you're
just a novel thing from the 19th
century. Because I like to talk about
that stuff too, Stephen, and maybe we
could talk about that some off air. Um,
I don't know how familiar you are with
like Presbyterian history, but people
oftentimes confuse Presbyterianism with
the Presbyterian movement. Um, and that
Presbyterianism has a history. We're
going back, I mean, Church of Scotland
time long before even the Protestant
Reformation. Um, and so it's interesting
to get into those sorts of things with
them because a lot of them have never
had this sort of stuff presented to
them. So, I'm thinking about how they're
hearing some of the things that you're
saying right now. And uh but a lot of
them are probably thinking, well, it
sounds Roman Catholic or um these types
of things. Um and really it just shows
there's a richer history out there that
except I'm talking about India and I'm
talking about Africa. I'm talking about
the British Isles and I'm talking about
other and I mean I've hardly talked
about Rome in this. I'm talking beyond
Rome.
Well, and see this gets back to
something else that you said earlier
though about how there is sort of this
mindset of like um almost like a false
dichotomy. Um and that's the sort of
thing the restorationist works in. it
was Rome and then our group. Everyone
else was really just kind of like
nestled under that sort of umbrella if
you will. And then our group is now
really breaking away from that which the
Adventist paradigm um if you read Ellen
White etc. Uh there is no understanding
of Eastern Christianity
of course not
at all. There there's no mention of
anything. It's it's a strictly western
paradigm. Um and that's sort of that
insight that you get from a lot of these
individuals. Joseph Smith was that same
way. um he had a very western mindset,
American centric mindset going on.
But continuing our theme of examining
these groups, notice what the Jehovah's
Witnesses
claim in this regard. This is from an
article on their website where they say
uh or the title was who was the founder
of Jehovah's Witnesses. They say quote
the modern-day organization of Jehovah's
Witnesses began at the end of the 19th
century. Notice they say modern-day
organization.
At that time, a small group of Bible
students who lived near Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania in the United States began
a systematic analysis of the Bible. They
compared the doctrines taught by the
churches with what the Bible really
teaches. They began publishing what they
learned in books, newspapers, and the
journal that is now called the
Watchtower Announcing Jehovah's Kingdom.
Among that group of sincere Bible
students was a man named Charles Tae
Russell. While Russell took the lead in
the Bible education work at that time
and was the first editor of the
Watchtower, he was not the founder of a
new religion.
The goal of Russell and other Bible
students, as the group was then known,
was to promote the teachings of Jesus
Christ and to follow the practices of
the first century Christian
congregation.
Since Jesus is the founder of
Christianity, we view him as the founder
of our organization. Colossians 1 18-20.
Same sort of thing. The local churches
of the day were corrupted to the core.
And when the early millennial Donist,
which was their early name, started
reading the Bible, they saw what it
really teaches and it wasn't being
followed by the other churches. They
weren't starting a new religion
supposedly, but they were apostolic
Christianity restored, the Mormon sect.
From a historical page on their website
where they are telling the story of
Joseph Smith, notice, quote, Joseph was
told that all the churches were wrong.
They had corrupted the doctrine, had
changed the ordinances, and had lost the
authority of the priesthood. And that
he, unlearned, but humble, was to be the
instrument through whom the Almighty
would re-establish
his work. Close quote.
Speaking on the churches of Christ and
Alexander Campbell, this is in truth
magazine, which is published by the
churches of Christ, Bill Humble writes,
quote, Franklin H. Little began by
speaking of the fact that restitution
often used by scholars instead of
restoration as a concept has gained
ground recently outside the so-called
restoration movement.
Tracing the roots of the concept of the
reformation,
Little cited what he called a fault line
of geographical proportions
between the magisterial reformation
stressing continuity sometimes through
apostolic succession with New Testament
times and the radical reformation
stressing discontinuity and therefore a
need for drastic measures to restore
apostolic Christianity.
These latter stressed restitution or
restoration of the primitive church
rather than reform of the existing
structures of corrupted Christianity.
Close quote. So very clear distinction
between reformation and restoration.
Brothers my question for you guys.
What are some paricopies of scripture
that show why this is an error?
Well, um, we've been kind of hitting on
this all night, um, in my opinion, but
you can't divorce the bride from Christ
at any point in history. You can't say
this eternal kingdom somehow failed. You
can't say that the Holy Spirit checked
out at some point in history. And so,
um, help me list off some of those
passages. I always like to go back to
what we've been talking about. Um,
Matthew 16 verse 18. Now, it's funny cuz
me me being Baptist, you got to forgive
me a little bit, Stephen. But, um, I do
see, you know, Peter hearkening the
confession that that Christ is the son
of the living God. And this is the the
cornerstone, the chief cornerstone which
Christ is building his church. but not
to neglect how foundational those
apostles are to that confession, always
pointing back uh to Christ. Just like
John the Baptist, behold the lamb of God
that takes away the sins of the world.
So, um Matthew 16 is kind of always my
go-to uh John 14:15 and 16, but the
spirit of truth guiding uh the apostles
and therefore by extension the church
into all truth. And I love the passage
that you quoted from um second John
saying like like the truth will always
be with God's people.
I I I kind of wonder. So I I guess you
should answer the question first. The
the main point that I was making. I
think we've already answered it multiple
times actually throughout this. Uh
whether you're talking about 2 John 1 or
John 14 being a big one. Even just the
great commission itself in Matthew 28.
Such a good point.
Uh I think is good. Acts one. Also, what
did what did Paul mean when he took a
guy named Timothy who was not an
eyewitness to Jesus
and gave him a deposit?
He gave him the truth and he told him to
commit it only to faithful men, not to
lay hands suddenly on anyone. He's
talking about a guarding and a
protecting. The apostles knew
that when they died, error would come
into the church because it was happening
while they were alive. So when these
individuals say they have, well, we're
seeking to uh bring back first century
Christianity.
Uh well, first century Christianity,
what about other documents? We have
documents for the first century. I just
read from one first clement. We have a
writing called the dedicay which the
full the only full copy we have it is in
codeex H the one I did my dissertation
on.
None of those churches are practicing
what the dedicay taught. That's first
century Christianity. They were doing
Eucharist every gathering. Um they had
bishops.
They had priests. See the thing that one
of those quotes was at the very end
there is that there there was a loss
from Jose Joseph Smith there. there's a
loss to the priesthood. Which priesthood
you referring to? If you're referring to
the priesthood of Christ, uh we don't
need a priesthood of the Levitical line
because Christ fulfilled that. If you're
talking about priests in the sense of
the priesthood of the presbyeteers,
uh then no, we actually can trace that
line. It's not been lost. Uh you just
refuse to read it. uh when you're
dealing with these these things about
the first century, we find the apostles
students continuing their doctrine. That
is what Paul was saying to Timothy.
That's Clement was under Peter and Paul.
Ignatius knew John himself, wrote
letters to the churches. Polycarp was
with John who trained Irenaeus who's
called a heretic. Um he had the
doctrines of John. He had the teachings
of John. He had the traditions of John
because he was under the succession of
John. They're saying there's this major
disconnect, but yet history tells us
there's a major connect. And who was it
that the first century writers and
second century writers were appealing to
for their doctrine? The scripture. Yeah.
The New Testament scripture. They they
appealed to it over their own authority.
They didn't take over the church.
Ignatius said that multiple times. He
said, "I I I could command this stuff to
you, but I don't have the authority of
Peter and Paul." That's what Ignatius
said to the church. I have authority,
but I can't command you the way Peter
and Paul commanded you. Why? Because he
knew the apostles authority was supreme
to his authority. Uh Polycarp, as I
stated, appealed to the writings of Paul
to the Philippians over against his own
writing. Clement did the same thing to
the Corinthians over his own writing.
Why? because they knew that the
authority was given to the apostles.
They were only guardians of that truth,
reminding the church of what they always
had.
So, there's another passage of scripture
that um ties in with what you're saying
from Paul to Timothy that I want to
encourage people, especially if they go
check out the apologetic dog. Shameless
plug. Um embedded in my logo is 1
Timothy 6 verse 20 into 21. But it ti
Stephen, I I want to talk about this for
just a moment because it ties into the
the living voice of God is ultimately
what is being preserved sovereignly over
time by God. But Paul tells Timothy,
"Oh, Timothy, guard the deposit
entrusted to you." What's that deposit?
It's that gospel of grace. It's what
Jude refers to as the faith that has
been once delivered to God's people,
right? And so he says, "Avoid." two
things to avoid, two two metrics by
which we can judge what is of God, his
truth, um, inspired by the Holy Spirit
and how to avoid that. He goes, "Avoid
irreverent babble." Now, my deep dive
into this is essentially pagan
philosophy, those heresies that are
creeping in unawares, as we've been
talking about, and avoid, Timothy,
contradictions of what is falsely called
knowledge. And so in my pursuits of
apologetics and really trying to do
those internal critiques, the that which
is cloaking itself within the truth is
going to possess internal
contradictions. Meaning on its own
terms, it's going to shoot itself in the
foot. And so fine, brain your rival
pagan doctrine and let me show you how
it cannot stand the test of time on its
own terms. And so we vindicate the
truth. In verse 21 says, "For by
professing it, some have swerved from
the faith." This has been happening even
since the first century. This isn't just
some new apostasy that happened
thousands years later. No. There's a
strong continuity that you've been
emphasizing with the deposit of faith.
Yes. And that faith could be found where
well, you say, "Well, those are the
apostles." That's not what Paul was
saying. He said he gave it to Timothy.
He deposited it to a man who was in one
of Paul's churches who had Paul's
teachings, Paul's letters, and that is
the line of succession. That dep that
that deposit was given to him, and he
told that man to commit it to faithful
men. It's what he was told to do. I at
least appreciate that that Church of
Christ article from Truth magazine was
actually correct in the distinction
between the magisterial reformation. Um,
and you see Stephen here, folks using
language that um, that individual
mentioned, things like apostolic
succession, etc. And it shows the stark
contrast between reformation and
restoration. Not the same thing. And
like the clip we saw in the beginning,
that's not at all what was going on with
the reformation.
Now, in light of all of that, I want to
transition to the final thing here,
which is looking at a statement from the
Adventist church's prophetus. Her words
with regards to the great apostasy. Now,
these are the words that carry the most
weight in this organization, more than
James White, more than just the Review
and Herald, more than any scholars, etc.
For those that might be new here, the
SDA organization claims this woman's
writings are divinely inspired, no
differently than the Bible is. Without
getting into all the word play that they
try to use on that, a bit of a long
quote here, but I want us to examine
this. So, let me get this brought up
here.
Okay,
notice
it's a claim to be given a vision from
God on the matter. She asserts
this.
I was carried forward to the time when
he idoltors cruy persecuted and killed
the Christians.
Blood flowed in torrancets. The noble,
the learned, and the common man were
alike slain without mercy. Wealthy
families were reduced to poverty because
they would not yield their religion.
Notwithstanding the persecution and
sufferings which these Christians
endured, they would not lower the
standard. They kept their religion pure.
I saw that Satan exalted and triumphed
over their sufferings. But God looked
upon his faithful martyrs with great
approbation. The Christians who lived in
that fearful time were greatly beloved
of him because they were willing to
suffer for his sake. Every suffering
endured by them increased their reward
in heaven. Although Satan rejoiced
because of the sufferings of the saints,
yet he was not satisfied. He wanted
control of the mind as well as the body.
The sufferings that they endured only
drove them closer to the Lord, leading
them to love one another and causing
them to fear more than ever to offend
him. Satan wished to leave them to
displease God, then they would lose
their strength, fortitude, and firmness.
Although thousands were slain, yet
others were springing up to supply their
places. Satan saw that he was losing his
subjects. For although they suffered
persecution and death, they were secured
to Jesus Christ to be the subjects of
his kingdom. Satan therefore laid his
plans to fight more su successfully
against the government of God and
overthrow the church. He led the heathen
idoltors to embrace a part of the
Christian faith.
Catch that. He led the heathen idoltors
to embrace a part of the Christian
faith. They profess to believe in the
crucifixion and resurrection of Christ
and proposed to unite with the followers
of Jesus without a change of heart. Oh,
the fearful danger of the church. It was
a time of mental anguish. Some thought
that if they should come down and unite
with those idolattors who had embraced a
portion of the Christian faith, it would
be the means of their full conversion.
Satan was seeking to corrupt the
doctrines of the Bible. I saw that at
last the standard was lowered and that
the heathen were uniting with the
Christians. Although these worshippers
of idols professed to be converted, they
brought their idolatry with them into
the church, only changing the objects of
their worship to images of saints and
even of Christ and of Mary his mother.
As the followers of Christ gradually
united with them, the Christian religion
became corrupted and the church lost its
purity and power. Some refused to unite
with them such preserved their purity
and worshiped God alone. They would not
bow down to an image of anything in the
heavens above or in the earth beneath.
Satan exalted over the fall of so many.
And then he stirred up the fallen church
to force those who would preserve the
purity of their religion either to yield
to their ceremonies and image worship or
be put to death. The fires of
persecution were again kindled against
the true church of Christ and millions
were slain without mercy. close quote.
So, claiming to be given a vision from
God on the matter, she asserts that the
church established
by the apostles became overrun with what
became Roman Catholicism such that
people were professing to be Christians,
but they were actually idolattors.
She was then supposedly shown that Satan
stirred up this false church to
persecute the true church which they
then claimed went into hiding in the
wilderness which is where you'll get
them appealing to Martin Luther and the
Babylonian captivity of the church. But
again, Martin Luther did not have the
same view and definition of the church
as these sectarians do. She then goes on
in the next chapter to say that the man
of sin and mystery of iniquity, which
James White, her husband, referred to
back in that previous statement, is the
pope. And that true Christianity had
become totally corrupted at this point
when popes and priests presumed to take
an exalted position and taught the
people to look to them for their pardon
of their sins instead of looking to
Christ. So my final question to you both
of you, how accurate is this retelling
of church history? And any final
thoughts that you have?
It's conspiratorial at best. Um, and it
is nearsighted.
Again, you're ba she's basing the
entirety of the true church or what was
a church on Rome
and Rome only. Number two, she's created
a grand universal conspiracy.
For something like this to be pulled
off, you would expect schism.
You'd expect outcry.
If one of the churches of the apostles
started doing something idolatrous and
adding in this massive horrendous evil,
the other churches in the world should
have been in schism against them and
rising up in debate. That's not what we
find. We actually find these churches
coming together for ecumenical councils.
We find them coming together to make
major decisions amongst their bishops
and what they had always been taught. We
find letters like the church in Carthage
and the council of Hippo writing to the
church of Rome making sure that the
documents they were getting in the
church with apostles names on them were
also faulty because they had the correct
doctrine and the correct documents from
the true apostles that were passed down.
You see, if there truly was something
like this that happened in Rome, there
would have been major global schisms.
The biggest falling ways we actually
seen between churches like the east and
the west particularly was oversteps of
Rome and silly things like the filioquay
whether or not the spirit proceeded from
the father and the sun. The nyian creed
being adapted and changed by Rome. It
wasn't major doctrinal issues. Both
eastern and western churches believe
that the son according to John 14 was
also sending the holy spirit. But it was
canon law being broken that caused the
schism. Schism was happening but not
over this kind of stuff. what she would
what she said of history has to be a
grand global conspiracy without phones,
without email, without YouTube, without
any kind of group chats or v or or any
kind of idea that we have in the modern
age where all these churches across the
world
come together without any way of doing
it and agree to fall into the same
heresy.
leaving no survivors.
Do you realize the statistical chance of
something like that happening when we
have evidence or coming around the
truth? She's proposing that Rome pulled
off the greatest world conspiracy that
has ever happened and all other churches
in the world were duped into it without
counsel, without schism and just fell in
line.
But again, it's a narrowminded view and
narrow and nearsided view because she
demonstrated that once again she
believes all history of truth and church
goes through one city.
Well, this is your wheelhouse speaking
to the history and I I like your appeal
to this grand conspiracy and thinking
about the percentage of that happening.
That's that's maybe your evidentialism
coming out there a little bit. Uh, but
that's good. It's just reminding people
of church history, like this is bonkers.
And the only thing I want to add is when
you have a gospel of grace and you can
clearly demonstrate that in the
scripture, it's not hard to point at
heretics in church history to say,
"Look, conflation, law, grace. This is
no different than any other religion in
the world that's saying, hey, obey this
list of commands. Remember to keep the
Sabbath holy. You you Protestants are
forgetting, right? You got to remember
it. It's like no uh you know the who the
sun sets free is free indeed and it's by
faith apart from your own
accomplishments the things that you do.
It's looking to the one who accomplished
them perfectly. And we're not saying
that um works don't have their their
great place. But if th those are the
things you're pointing to for your
justification before God. Stephen, I I
want to upplay and remind Baptists, hey,
church history, amazing. Christ has been
building his church, but it's so easy to
just point them to the living voice of
God. Uh the sheep hear the voice of the
good shepherd. Let's let's point them to
the finished work of Christ. And yes, we
can kind of look through church history
to see how Christ has been sanctifying
the bride, but it to me, it's just not
hard to see the damaged goods of LG
White. Um, it's so easy to show the
damaged goods of Alexander Campbell that
once again is is showing us a faulty
gospel, not one that we can clearly show
with the the deposit that's been
entrusted to us. And so that's obviously
where I lean in some of these things.
And I think maybe you can speak to this
a little bit, but people get swept away
into these restorationist movements that
do not have a good grounding in the word
of God. And um a lot of these people are
are prime candidates um the harvest
field of of just sharing the gospel with
them, right? They're gonna they're going
to say they believe in the Bible. Well,
if we can just show them to clear
passages of how one is made right with
God, I think that's going to do
essentially the heavy lifting for us.
But I don't want that to be misheard of
saying we should just strip out church
history altogether.
Yeah. No, we don't need to strip it out.
And and again uh the grand global
conspiracy that she is proposing. The
one time we see a massive sweep of
something was aranism.
Aranism started in Alexandria made
itself heavy into the east and what
happened? A whole council had to meet to
solve it.
We don't see that happening prior to
that where a grand global conspiracy
leaves the faith to take on pagan
idolatrous practices.
And everybody just stood by and said,
"Oh, sure. Yeah, we'll start doing that,
too. That sounds like a great idea."
anything that opposed the original
teachings of the churches that made that
kind of move via
aranism.
It caused such a stir or Marcian
corrupting and doing his thing in the
second century. It created such a stir
that the churches had to respond
universally to it. So again, u my invite
to anybody is come back to Mama Church.
There's plenty of apostles churches
still around. They're not perfect. They
need to be cleansed, repenting, and
things like that. They're out there. Um
I I'm I'm not uh I'm not a pastor at
Harvest Anglican. I am a curate. Uh
that's in the candidacy for ordination.
So that's that's what I'm doing there to
kind of clarify from earlier miles. um
uh doing a curacy uh at the church and
uh but definitely looking forward to uh
the path that's going to be. We invite
anybody back to the truth. Uh if if you
have fallen into error scripturally
uh historically,
just the truth is easy to find today.
It's available, but there's a lot of
lies out there. continue to listen to
programs like this one or like
Jeremiah's or a little plug to mine
facts. Um, what we argue for is from
evidence. We're not giving you a
hypothetical world or a hypothetical
history. We can point you down the trail
of truth and it starts in scripture and
it's prevailed to today.
Yeah. And you pointed out a a a number
of good things there regarding her
historical bankruptcy, but you also get
a glimpse there into this sort of like,
well, there was this great apostasy and
you know, Irenaeus, Athanasius, uh
they're all lumped in with these like
they adopted these pagan practices. They
were these these fake faux Christians
that were actually idoltors. the true
church was this persecuted group, but we
don't really know where they were
or who they were.
That's kind of you getting it. Yeah,
that's you kind of getting an insight
into that. Like all the ones that are
known, well, they were heretics. And
this typically for them gets into like,
well, they they didn't keep the seventh
day Sabbath because Ellen White in the
same book also claimed that all true
Christians back to the apostles from the
apostles have kept the seventh day
Sabbath, which is a whole another
discussion that maybe we will save for
another day.
I did a whole episode on that. I did a
whole episode on that if you want to go
on Spotify or whatever. I did uh Sabbath
or Sunday.
Um when did the church church meet? And
I demonstrate multiple evidence of
church fathers talking about their
gathering on Sundays even in the first
century. So
yeah, and when you do that with them,
you'll tend to get well that's not the
Bible. And it's oftentimes like, well,
I'm citing this as a historical source
because your history is off here. You're
climbing historically. At least she is.
And she's a higher authority than you
are, Joe Mo Adventist. Um The Adventist
Church is telling us this is divinely
inspired. And she's claiming that all
true Christians back from the apostles
to the present day were seventh day
sabotarians, which is just an insane
statement. So that's why you'll get
these claims where it's like, well, what
about Ignatius's epistles? Oh, all seven
of them were forgeries.
No.
Oh. Oh, true.
They they were. I've heard him say
things like, "Well, in his epistle when
he talks about the Lord's day, he's
actually talking about the seventh day
Sabbath." Oh. Even though in the context
he's arguing against seventh day
sabotarianism.
There are
there are pseudo letters but most
scholars
Yeah. But those are the other seven.
Okay.
Yeah. There's 14 total and then seven of
them are are pretty unanimously
understood to be forgeries. But not the
other seven. Not the letter to the
Magnesians for example. Not you know
this idea that um that's why they get
caught in this catch22. They have to
say, well, he was a heretic then
according to Ellen White because Ellen
White said the true Christians were the
ones that were keeping the seventh day
Sabbath and he wasn't. So is Ignatius,
one of the the disciples of the
apostles, he was a heretic, but a woman
in the 19th century
that claimed that she was given the
theological God particle, the theory of
everything, the the antidote to
theological division, more revelation
given through her than anyone else
that's ever lived. We just looked at
that quote, what was that last week,
folks? I don't know. We've looked at it
I don't know how many times. It's on the
website. They can try and twist and bend
your arm all you out of context. Yeah.
Okay. No. She claimed that more
revelation was given in these days
through her because it's ultimately
Jesus. It's not her. It's Jesus. But
he's given more revelation in this day
in this period for this people. And it's
the most solemn warning message ever
given to the world. The 7th Adventist
Church's unique message. So, all of that
to say, they have to get caught in this
catch22 when you start talking about
history. And again, this kind of circles
us right back to the whole idea of of
restorationism and its sort of
historical bankruptcy that it produces,
not just scriptural bankruptcy, but the
fact that you basically have to, like
you said, say that all of history is
just this massive conspiracy. And this
is why I'm constantly telling you
Adventists, you need to put down the
Ellen White books and read actual church
history. The Great Controversy is not
real history. I say this a lot here.
It's not real history, folks. It is an
adaptation. It is the equivalent of
based on a true story that you find at
the beginning of a film that uses real
events, but what you see on screen is an
adaptation. They add stuff in for
interest to spice up the storyline etc.
That is what you are getting in the
great controversy. It is not history.
It's not real history. It uses real
figures, etc. So, I'm not saying it's
fake figures because I know I'll get
Adventists that will be like, "Are you
saying Martin Luther wasn't real?" No,
it's not real history. It's using these
figures and it is adapting those things,
but twists them to fit with the
extra-biblical great controversy
worldview. Brothers, thank you so much
for being here. I think this was very
beneficial for a number of people across
the board. Maybe we can do something
like this again in the future for
another topic or on another topic. And
thank you the viewer for being here as
well. May Christ richly bless you in the
grace and peace won by him and his
vicarious death on the cross for your
sins. Hallelujah. And marinatha.
[Music]